the following is a presentation of the
St Louis chess
club winter has arrived at the singfield
cup in St Louis there's a chill in the
air but these Grand Masters have ice in
their veins Fabiano Carana may run away
with the GCT title but that isn't
keeping him from trying to rack up
another trophy in the process defeating
the current leader to join him in co-
first lenar Dominguez is on a roll
winning his second game in a row to join
the leaders at the top of the standings
there's a three-way tie with
opportunities for points dwindling round
eight of amazing chess coming up
[Music]
next
welcome to round eight of the singfield
cup we have only two rounds left and
tensions are high there's a lot on the
line let's get back to the studio and
get
started we welcome you to St Louis the
home of Chess in America with two rounds
left we are tied at the top will someone
take the lead we will find out today and
it all starts right
now hello and welcome and let's get
ready ready because it's the penultimate
round at the sink Bill cup and after
yesterday's dramatic day we now have two
new leaders vying for that top spot but
with two rounds remaining anything can
happen in this test of nerves skill and
strategy I'm International Master Ian
kuska and as always it's a great
pleasure to be alongside these two very
fine and very clever grandm yes San and
Peter Sidler we take no credit we take
no credit Joy it's it's always a
pleasure to be with you and as well for
you Peter hello everyone and welcome to
the penultimate round indeed we have
crowned a grand chest T Champion one
Fabiano Karana not surprisingly has won
the GCT tour but as far as the singfield
Cup Tournament itself it just feels like
anything can happen Joy do the honors
tell us our standings in abely with
pleasure yasa and uh here we can see the
standings of the tournament and it's a
two-way tie at the top between Fabiana
caruana and lenia Dominguez both on four
points out of six also on four points is
Wesley so but he has four points out of
seven because of Yang Kristoff duda's
withdrawal in round two exactly and uh
as I said the GCT standings we know the
champion we're not sure who second and
third but there you see it is
uncatchable at the very top absolutely
is well he began the event with an
11-point Head Start Over Maxim vasra
well he needed a catastrophe to occur to
not win the grand chess tour and that
has not happened so therefore Fabiana
Carana is Grand chest tour Champion two
rounds to spare and there he Nets
$100,000 bonus what a year it's been for
Fabiano truly spectacular congrat
gratulations Fabby now tell us about the
format for this year syn P yes under 10
player round robin a classical time
control of 90 minutes for the first 40
moves and then 30 minutes for the rest
of the game and the players do get a 30
second increment time bonus from move
one no draw offers allowed but it's a
standard Point scoring system we let the
cat out of the bag as far as the
schedule is concerned but nonetheless do
your best what's our remaining schedule
well two rounds remaining and tomorrow
it is the final day everything will be
decided tomorrow and uh playoffs for
first place in the snc FI cup will also
happen tomorrow if needed we are about
crowning Champions here in St Louis and
Peter this event itself just feels like
it's wide open and several players can
win it absolutely and the last few days
provided us with plenty of excitement
but it does seem to be a three horse
race as you you will see on your screen
right now the current standing is as
Yanka has already explained Fabian
lenier on four out of six leading the
tournament and Wesley is the only other
player above a 50% Mark as you see them
uh highlighted they probably will end up
fighting fighting it out for the top
prizes although the people on 50% could
still have a say about it mhm and let's
take a look at the road ahead for our
three main contenders starting with ler
Dominguez who is uh still has two games
to play and his pairings as you will are
probably the toughest of the three has
white against mvl today black against
Leon in round nine two players on 50%
but playing a very decent tournament uh
overall next one is Wesley he is the
only one of the three who only has one
game left so everything for him depends
on his game today uh he plays White
against yanish a player he generally has
a pretty good score against but
yesterday's lost must not have been very
enjoyable for Wesley and has a Buy in
round nine and as for Fabian
uh who is completely triumphant into in
in in this year's Grand chest tour uh he
has two games left black against Anish
giri and white against R drport in the
last round two players who are uh below
the below the 50% Watermark so very
decent paing in the tournament as well
for Faby he might continue crushing for
all we know and it is my honor and my
privilege to to introduce woman Grand
Master Anastasia kich with more news
from the Chess
World thank you p hello everyone I'm
here for you not far from the plane
venue to and I'm waiting for the players
here to conduct the interviews with them
after the finish of their games we have
a beautiful day today in St Louis sun is
shining and I hope there will be really
really nice games as well um please
follow us in our social media accounts
Grand CH St St Louis chess club Twitter
Facebook Instagram everyone is waiting
for you there and um yesterday of course
we published the the post about um
Fabiano Carana who just won Grand chest
tour there are no theoretical chances
that anybody will catch him so two
rounds to spare Fabiano won the event
and he got also many many comments and
congrats um including 13th world
champion Gary Kasparov who told and who
sent in the tw Twitter that Fabiana
reached tremendous result uh if you want
to leave your comments and Congress to
Fabi please follow the social media
accounts and send the congratulations to
him believe me CH players are quite
active in the social Med and he will
definitely check them um also don't
forget to to check exclusive interviews
on the St Louis chess club YouTube page
um I have asked players about the State
of Affairs in the Chess World and they
gave very very interesting answers I'm
sure everybody will be curious to find
out what they think about the situation
in the Chess World on the top about
Magnus dingler and absence and many
other topics they discussed during those
interviews um and on this note I I think
it's time to go back uh to the studio
round 8 is coming and yes sir Joy now
it's your time you Anastasia I just saw
that uh quote there by Ali Raz as we see
Bobby entering uh the tournament Hall
says uh I started playing chess when
Magnus was world champion well I started
playing chess when fiser was World
Champion we have a lot in common and we
do and there we see Anish with the white
pieces making friendly banter with
Fabiana Carana and the players there
they are being asked to sign a
certificate authenticity absolutely for
the set that they're playing on uh Joy
do the honors tell our viewers what they
can expect with the pairings and I see
three incredibly important games please
absolutely we'll start off with perhaps
the least irrelevant Game Richard report
against leavon aronian but here it gets
really really tense giri who needs a
good performance for the FED circuit
standings well he has the white pieces
against Fabiano Carana who is already
Grand chest T Champion Lena Dominguez
who also is fighting for a rting spot
for the speo 2024 candidates he has the
white pieces against Maxine Vash lra and
wle so who has a fight on both these
things the circuit and the rating spots
well he has the white pieces against Yan
nomachi and Ali Resa fuja does have a bu
because of yan Kristof dudo withdrawal
in round two exactly and again there you
see the players as they getting started
it it's it almost seems
like what are the players fighting for
seems like they're playing fighting for
a lot those candidates going to start
jangling I mean yesterday Fabiano said
that he felt that he beat Wesley because
Wesley was feeling nervous but here you
can see what is at stake first first
price first place Nets
$100,000 second place
$65,000 thirdd place
$48,000 as well as Grand chest to points
and it's about those grand chest tour
points as well because the top three
finishers in the grand chest tour get
bonuses of $50 and
$225,000 as well as an automatic invite
to the next uh year cycle as this one
this player has come out of nowhere
lanir Dominguez I mean he doesn't lose
games we've been making hey about that
but boy his backto back victories has
suddenly catapulted him nobody chose
laner in the predictions but look what
he's doing in the ratings yes and take a
look at this one Wesley so in the live
ratings has
2757 but Lena Dominguez improving his
rating to
2756 just one point between them and for
Ali Resa fuja well he started the
beginning of November with
2777 but it's all gone downhill from
then on the Fall From Grace indeed as uh
play is underway and again for Anish if
he and of course he's very ambitious he
wants to make it to the candidates uh a
victory today
is absolutely huge uh for those
aspirations Peter and he's uh chosen the
Catalan yeah so this I I think is the
first proper Catalin of the tournament
so uh both players are Inc incredibly
well booked up and are playing the the
absolute uh main line so far no no fancy
fancy replies to the Catland fa
DET should I I need to stop talking
because obviously as as I was saying
that uh no no funky funky stuff is being
employed t76 is a move that has been
around forever
this in my childhood when I used to play
these openings with black before I
discovered the grimfeld this was my
preferred reply to the Catan which
really is probably
an an indication that it shouldn't be
played if anything but uh the idea for
black is pretty straightforward you
develop the Knight obviously it now goes
to D7 C6 is closed you often play B7 B6
and the bishop gets developed to either
B7 or A6
it's very very solid but it does give
white time to perhaps play something
like Queen C2 followed by perhaps the
the simplest plan here would be
something like Queen C2 followed by
Knight bg2 followed by E2 E4 trying to
assume uh control in the center and the
main thing is when white gets in E2 E4
black lets that tension stand and there
has been some new wrinkles with the
Knight coming out to A6 and C7 as well
que already already played by by a Nish
exactly well again uh these these
players are playing
pretty fast I was going to say but C7 C6
uing all of those Bishop B4 check ideas
and and also the main line is dx4 which
is what I was expecting exactly uh I'm
going to switch quickly because Wesley
so and uh Yan are I think Wesley more
than anybody is probably played this
this particular position this makes me a
bit apprehensive to be honest yes short
draw because why exactly uh this is the
very very topical or at least it used to
be very very topical line of the nimzo
allowing the nimzo playing Queen C2
Queen C2 is by far the main move here D5
is a very playable alternative to the to
the short castles here but this is the
main move and now after A3 you get slow
maneuvering positions very often right
but there is also this movie to E4 which
is incredibly principled and is
definitely staking a claim for big
advant AG but unfortunately for for why
these days I think it went to E2 today
right uh these positions because I think
Knight of3 may be also playable but it
leads to same positions anyway right
this has been analyzed into absolute
dust uh and my understanding is if black
doesn't forget something black makes a
reasonably comfortable draw very often
without really even needing to remember
very much because this has been
internalized by the black players by
this point and the the main line goes
along the lines of Bishop F4 Queen H4 G3
the queen drops back to I think H5 here
castles G5 very very important move here
because you need to start challenging
the white setup and now Mass exchanges
in the center very often result in very
very level in end games I have a feeling
even those two players have played this
against each other already I have the
same yeah and by the way the players are
following exactly this is this is being
blitzed out at at a break net speed
including castles includ including
Castles by this point there really sharp
line where white can Castle Queen side
but gain some am maybe I'm getting my I
can't recall exactly where but I I I'm
not really an imza player I've just been
watching people making this draw over
and over and over again in in in terms
of playing this for a win I think the
move Bishop F4 E3 is the one I I need to
make I think maybe it goes cd5 B D5
Bishop B3 with the intention of playing
this position okay which to begin with
feels like black is just a pawn up but
there's a lot of compensation because
the white setup on on the king side is
more uh is more harmonious and also
black play G7 G5 which is never a great
idea but yeah Wesley seems uh
fairly uh uninterested in that he's
already taken cd5 Knight takes C3 is a
response and I think yeah I think this
is the position which leads to this very
very equal end game which they they have
been uh playing a lot these days so D
already played Black takes this bishop
takes on G3 takes on D7 B takes C3
seemingly black is in trouble but Rook a
C8 is a very important move using the
the X-ray along the C file and either
Queen D1 first or Bishop F5 first they
basically lead to more or less the same
position here you play Queen D1 very
clever move unpinning all of our pieces
solving all of our tactical issues here
and here for instance after Rook C4 uh
all the pieces come off extremely
quickly I think there was a notable game
where I think mvl won this with the
white people against somebody in the
Champions chest yeah where Anish I think
assumed a draw for is coming soon and
and had other ideas and by the time
Anish realized this is an actual game
being played he was already slightly
worse and he couldn't really readjust to
to having to defend it but strictly
speaking this is not very much like
Bishop D7 I think the game went
something like this and Anish ended up
losing some kind of an end game like
this which yes you can lose if you if
you if you just pay no ention for the
next 15 moves and allow white to make a
lot of progress on the king side right
but obviously this isn't very much equal
material opposite color Bishops very few
pieces left on the board and yeah they
are they so so far have progressed up to
B Tak C3 but honestly this is and you
have to you have to talk about this this
is uh Wesley's General
approach he is unbelievably good when
you give him winning chances but he also
very often just aims for
very very safe continuations with zero
risk but also not a lot of prospect of
winning a game exactly yeah well he has
told us in interviews that his main goal
for this event is to get the top three
standings on the grand chest tour and to
get a qualification in next year's uh
Grand chest Tour by the way I'm looking
at move 18 Wesley started the game with
90 minutes on his clock he now has 96
Minutes Yan say same now has 94 minutes
so both players uh very very much still
in their preparation and I suspect a lot
more preparation especially once you
told me about the MV Anish game somebody
loses that ending suddenly you're going
to pay more attention to the position
you probably look it up a bit little you
figure out exactly how to hold it where
else uh would you like to go very very
interesting things is going on in the
game between Lenard Dominguez and Maxim
gra because we got distracted first by
the Catlin and then by that Nimo in the
game between Wesley and Yan y but I did
I was in time to see you 4 C5 and I
thought wonderful another really sharp
nther yeah because they've played even
here on this Hallowed Ground in St Louis
they played some unbelievable uh fights
in these long n with opposite color
castling and uh there was my expectation
but no today uh andil does something I
haven't seen him do very much he goes
for the snik in particular he goes with
for the S of why this move order
allowing white a very
fashionable uh thing to do which if you
choose between the two move orders that
might lead to the fing of this allows
the rala right so people would I think
generally prefer this one because the
rosala is a huge body of theory these
days you really need to study it but the
issue with this one is it allows Knight
Tak C6 but lineer seems to be completely
fine completely fine with the idea of
playing the the main line sikov but uh
mvl does something that has existed for
for decades but I think is very very
unfashionable which is the move Knight
E7 because I think most people these
days play either Rook B8 or Bishop G5
I'm also not very uh certain about my
snik of M orders but I think this is the
current T and this is what we people
generally discuss here quite a bit but
97 is a move that leads to completely
different structure because you you you
don't really want to allow Knight takes
D5 followed by Bishop E6 that will
immediately solve most of Black's issues
so you have to take on F6 now black
structure looks even more
raggedy than than it did a moment ago
but after uh the bishop comes out to B7
both F5 breaks and in particular D6 D5
breaks are going to be available pretty
much every move I think the person I
sort of associate this line with is mhal
cenov I I think he played a great deal
of this maybe 30 years ago but that's I
think where the height of popularity for
this was I think Vladimir Kik doubled in
in this particular line of the SES at
some point but he played everything in
SES you're right there Peter most of the
games that I'm looking at are like
2000 and cenov is in there Magnus
Carlson also beat Yan pomi in this
line on the black side on the black side
sorry yeah and how do how does lanir and
match up with NBL JY yes and uh wait for
it and look at this one win each and
seven draws I demand to know where did
NBL win that one game it wasn't in the
sink Bill cup I you know we have to call
for an
investigation he Lena doesn't lose in
the sinkfield cup no he doesn't so it
had to be somewhere overse the
fashionable thing is to demand an
examination apparently I see there are
whole petitions dedicated to um this
specific position Joy after Bishop D3
what's the most theoretical uh
continuation for black does black play
D5 D5 D isal popular move like also
dabbled with F5 but that looks maybe a
little bit too much but D5 very natural
also G8 has been played yeah what
happens after D5 how does the line
continue D5 uh Pawn takes Pawn okay well
oh queen2 is also very playable I think
the reason I didn't want to play Queen
E2 is I got scared of F5 of F5 and then
suddenly he's like did I trap my Bishop
what did I just do uh but this this
actually is is an important thing to to
have under control because yes the
bishop now on D3 it has very few squares
if any but tactically apparently it
works out after F6 because after e takes
D3 the only move for white here is the
move F takes E7 leaving our own Queen on
prze right but we end up being very very
far ahead because black probably has to
take on E7 and now this is basically
winning because this is horrible this is
even even worse in a way yeah so and
after F6 of the KN goes somewhere really
anywhere there's now a pin along the E
file allowing us allowing us one more
move to to stabilize and then material
is equal but this Knight on D4 will
dominate the game for the rest of the
game basically so this is not very good
good for black at all so que2 is
playable the engine suggests just
offload offloading everything the thing
about that though is these end games are
not entirely equal to begin with because
of the structure being a bit compromised
it whoa okay okay by the way Queen E2 F5
on the board okay this is very confusing
because at first blush the engine really
hates it which is which is which is why
I'm I'm so I'm so surprised but this is
clearly something that mvl uh checked
checked at home you you don't do this as
quickly if if you don't know exactly
what you're doing so let's investigate a
bit further so how would you how would
you proceed from here I hate this for
black I'm just thinking that mvl may be
gambiing a pawn after e takes F5 with
something like Queen D6 and just saying
oh you won a pawn how how good or bad is
it the engine says I'm I'm very happy
you haven't played e54 because you
probably will never play E5 for now
right we can choose where we Castle are
you sure well I can tell you what
everyone has been playing so everyone
after e takes F5 has been going E4 and
after F6 it's not Pawn takes Bishop but
Knight to F5 specifically F5 I think to
deny deny why D3 Square for the queen
and in this position the main line
appears to be F3 Queen takes F6 and then
White Castles King side because if you
if you take on e4 you aren't actually
winning the pawn because Queen H4 check
is uh quite annoying G3 Knight takes G3
is playable and black ends up winning
the pawn on e4 back so you can Castle to
which black can for instance include
Queen B6 check which maybe is just
required honestly everything else seems
to be much worse and then the Knight
Knight drops back to D6 and we end up
King H1 let's say let's say Rook F2
because King H1 there's also this very
quirky idea of playing Queen H6 and say
we should this idea Knight
G3 so I think Rook F2 is stronger and
now
the engine protects the pawn on e4 okay
and let's stop here and discuss this for
a second I think structurally this is
very very good for
white uh and also you have to mention
that the king will be going quinide
which if you give white time quinide
will eventually get open it will go
badly for black right but you will
probably have at some point uh oh let's
uh over because we could get there three
move repetition in the game between an
giri and Fabiana
Carana well that opening was very
interesting but let's figure out what
happened how did repeat standard
standard Catan repetition of bishop4
Knight H5 Bishop Beck Knight
F6 uh
sorry yeah standard repetition oh yes
Knight H5 uh forgot about that and
Bishop D we used to call these the
grandm draws and the the joke on the
circuit was uh I'm calling for grandmas
draw number 20 oh is that the Catalan
with Knight H5 yes that's the one kn5
Knight H5 Bishop back to D2 Knight back
um Anish Gary must have calculated that
a draw keeps his hopes for the candidacy
a l and also in a way um you know it's
regret regrettable that this happened
because we obviously wanted to watch
that game it looked like a mouthwatering
prospect but in a way I think in
particular after the inter he gave
yesterday he just I think he just wanted
to make it clear that he is not you know
there's no hanky panky involved here
because he he mentioned yesterday that
he's in a kind of a weird spot in terms
of the results in this game and the
there's been some speculation about the
hypothetical situations exactly like
that there was a very curious occasion
Ju Just as the F circuit was announced
mvl I think maybe a year ago tweeted
more or less calling them players a b
and c he tweeted more or less the exact
situation that we have right now where
uh Anish could be in a kind of a strange
situation where a draw is better for him
than a loss sorry the other way around
of course a l is better so Anish just
says no I'm I'm not interested in
discussing any of this I I feel like my
tournament isn't going well let's just
put pay to all of this speculations go
home play play tomorrow okay and that's
what we have we have our first result of
this penultimate round for Fai draw with
black thank you very much Anish Gary
keep say minus record not so good uh and
uh this is how it looks so far we can
see the round of eight results how many
minutes are we into the competition yeah
well we didn't even get around the horn
so it's uh not been that
much we're under the 30 minute Mark move
repetition in the opening for Anish giri
against Fabiano Carana Wesley and Yan
have gone
completely let's have a look at let's
just briefly briefly put this on the
board Mo 25 we're once again 20 minutes
into the round of their abouts right
this is the position it might not even
be a fresh position yet I'm pretty sure
games have reached here right so uh yeah
as as mentioned it is possible to lose
this but you have to work at it it's
it's not easy to lose this with black
right and I don't think Yan will succeed
I'm I'm I'm trying to imagine this the
sign the sign says Talent required um
continue with our let's go back yeah
let's go back with a very very sharp
position not to five already on the
board and the position we were
discussing after Knight F5 was this F3
Queen takes castles Queen B6 sh very
important otherwise black is in a lot of
trouble uh no not King H1 Rook F2 and
Knight D6 and I was saying that I think
structurally with the Knight coming over
to D4 this bishop one B7 currently not
being a very attractive piece black
pretty much having to Castle queenside
into potential opening of the files with
a to A4 it doesn't look like very much
fun but black has it their own trumps
here of course the pawn on e4 is
annoying because you either have to at
some point take and then the bishop on
B7 becomes a lot more alive MH or you
have to uh play as if it doesn't exist
something like this which I think would
be my initial preference right but then
you constantly have to worry about
allowing E4 E3 mhm uh for the time being
A4 is pretty much always going to be met
by B4 so the files aren't being opened
at the speed at the speed that why would
like right uh and it's it's not that
clear and also mvl is both of them are
playing very quickly but mvl clearly has
an idea here I have to say that you know
it's not easy for white to attack the
queen side either because you have to
you're doing it with one of your hands
tied right Queen isn't working I mean
and also White's king is not safe either
exctly so a fascinating position there
and I was I was being told that uh this
position or at least this line has been
played 3600 times in our database I mean
that's a that's a lot of games I mean a
lot of people have really explored this
variation how statistically yeah I was
like Wow statistically speaking how is
white doing uh on this line that JY on
this one after F3 for example it looks
like most of the games have ended in
draw oh yeah that's what I but I don't
have 3600 games in my day we we we we
have a small uh small data small
database uh and in the studio unless our
production is playing is Playing Tricks
on us that would indicate that this line
at some point became very popular in
correspondence chess yeah so a lot of
basically Engine versus engine games
were played starting from here and those
do tend to end in draws by the way do
you pay attention to the engine versus
engine games uh yourselves mean I try to
but they play so many yes there are a
lot of competitions are't there yeah and
the it's basically you know they finish
one long Marathon game and then they
start another game and then it keeps on
going but I mean I do follow uh grandmas
Matthew Sadler yes on Twitter and he's
the one who kind of keeps everyone
posted on very interesting Novelties
that have developed so definitely worth
uh checking out uh in terms of the super
engine the one from Norway what's the
CES sesi yeah yeah cool first of all
great name uh does cesie play in those
CI just follows um Magnus Carson and is
kind of an amp tapped version ofish yeah
CI is not an engine sessi is a
supercomputer running the latest the
latest stockfish so it's still stockfish
but uh the supercomputers do they get in
on those computer competitions like the
super computers with playing I think
stockfish plays Houdini plays I think
they play on stand standardized Hardware
because otherwise that would be a bit
unfair if one played if one played on
significantly better machine than the
other that would be a bit a bit iy you
know what I always wanted to see I
wanted to see like um you know how
during the pandemic the bookie set up
this kind of virtual horse racing with
all the legendary
horses really they had nothing else to
do but go on won and who won Red Rom Red
Rom yeah the the famous horse oh my gosh
not even uh the Secretariat come on well
I would like to see done with like the
former world champions give them like
all the same knowledge but just put
their Styles in and then see who's the
greatest that would be that would be
interesting but I just want I started
waving in our production here because I
think we should go to to the camera of
the game between Wesley and handshake
soon yeah today will be a two game round
a two game round as you're predicting a
draw yeah this one is this one is over
draw this one is over as it
gets I don't know Bishop B3
together they will end uh 15 minutes
above the starting
time Wesley Wesley yeah Wesley actually
ends the game on 1 hour 42 minutes and
some seconds which is 12 minutes above
the starting time which is an
achievement in a way whenever I see
colors of opposite color Bishops I'm
reminded of the quote by Boris basy oh
yeah about how he and his ex-wife were
like opposite color Bishop we were
Bishops of opposite color explaining his
divorce from his first wife uh yeah
exactly uh Wesley gains time on his
clock and that's Wesley's tournament
done by the way he doesn't play he
doesn't play tomorrow so he ends on plus
one and that actually gives us a much
clear picture of where we stand in terms
of all of those races actually it gives
us a kind of a fixed point to discuss
how other people are doing uh and in
terms of by the way on the way in we
were while we were being driven uh to to
the the studio where we're discussing
the topic of automatic qualification for
the next year's uh ground chest tour and
I said that it feels like this is more
or less nailed on with uh obviously
Fabby and then mvl and and Wesley
qualifying and this is what it looks
that's that's a different graphic though
the Fe elig we'll need that we'll need
that but a bit ler when we talk about
lineer but as far as the grand chest
tour is concerned you were about to say
the top three finisher up three finishes
of the gr chest tour and this is the gr
chest tour points we're talking about
we'll get we'll get an automatic uh
right to play in in in next year's
season I I'd just like to talk about
that for just a quick second because uh
I mean we can fault Wesley for you know
a short early draw but the idea is that
Wesley saying I'm a professional player
it's incredibly important for me to get
into the grand chest tour points chess
tour as a qualified player for example
lanir Dominguez is is here as a world a
wild card leavon aronian a many many
time player of the tour is here as a
wild card and it's a huge difference on
their bank accounts frankly
professionally speaking but they're also
showmen I mean the whole point of a
grand testor is to entertain the public
of course and you know to show us their
Brilliance I agree I agree I agree this
doesn't look that great but on the other
hand they're
competitors uh and they're trying to
qualify for the next year so if somebody
you know uh doesn't make a world record
but you know qualifies to the the next
event this is what we're talking about
Wesley so uh having secured a plus one
is now if if the tournament ends today
and all four games today are drawn
Wesley gets clear third which is nine
points yes and nine points will be
enough to finish in the top three for
sure because ala is having absolute
nightmare is nowhere to be seen exactly
what about Yan but yeah at% is yanan's
at 50% and Wesley just did himself a
favor by keeping y 50% because that was
the point I was going to bring up and
then I realized Wesley has also
calculated this because if Yan wins both
his last two games he probably Leap
Frogs Wesley even in the grand chest T
standings not just in the singfield cup
standings but but one of the games yan
yan is playing is that one we just watch
Westley Yan can only finish on plus one
maximum yeah and he is three points
behind uh no he's not three points
behind W uh 310 of a point yeah 310 of a
point behind Wesley which he will remain
yeah so uh that's actually a very
precise calculation there by by by
Wesley which appears to as far as we
understand it almost guarantee him uh
the top three finish maybe just maybe
just mathematically guarantee him a top
three finish a top three finish a
$25,000 bonus and an automatic
qualification to the next year's Grand
chest tour and again what I wanted to
say is that leavon and laner both are
not Grand chest Tor players this year
and they would desperately would love uh
to receive a ticket to uh an invit but
that would be that would be at at the
discretion of the the organizers of and
they do it strictly by Merit two games
today's one we haven't spoken about at
all but it's pretty sharp and very much
enjoying what I'm saying here once again
began as The The J of panima here with
the the absolute classical not even D3
on Mo four D3 on move 5 to make it
really really you know old school devel
develop all for
night
exactly I like to see the players taking
it back to their Roots exactly I think
in the one game we've had this
tournament where this was uh reached
black did play 7 H6 here not align
Bishop G5 at all but Leon says no let's
play a sharper oops sorry a sharper
version of the same Bishop G5 H6 Bishop
H4 the bishop drops back because 9 D5
was annoying annoying by this point yeah
A4 is a move they make very very often
just to preserve the bishop on this
diagonal and also gain some space but
mainly I think just to be able to keep
the bishop on the A2 G8 diagonal D6 and
seems a bit strange to we we've
retreated earlier but now we're taking
on F6 but this is a very standard thing
here because weirdly I think white
actually prefers trading this bishop for
a knight rather than trading it for the
bishop on E7 for
example yeah let's say castles black
very very seriously could consider
something like Knight H7 or Knight H5
trying to provoke the threade on E7 got
and what we're doing by trading on F6 is
we're saying we we now have decent light
Square control and also this bishop has
very little future in in in the
immediate because it's very much hemmed
in by blacks on pawns uh Leon plays G6
he generally likes I'm going to preserve
the bishop preserve the bishop and also
he Leon very much likes in all of these
Spanish and Italian positions to at
least hint he will play a five one day
yeah he is maybe the biggest proponent
of this let me just show it on the board
to to illustrate the idea of King h8
follow up by Knight G8 has been played
by Leon in about 20 different variations
we'll return to this but for now uh is
with a special guest in the other
Studio yes exactly I have Fabiano Carana
here with me the game with Nish giri
finished in the draw we haven't even
finished our coffee yet what happened in
this game BBY yeah so I had this thought
yesterday that maybe he doesn't really
want to win the game mhm just because
the candidates race is so weird that of
course he doesn't want like Wesley to
get a higher ranking in this tournament
because that would give Wesley the
better circuit tour this is basically
the explanation for what happened today
and actually I kind of I know that Anish
is like um he's kind of a master of like
body language so when he already played
his like first four moves he was playing
them so quickly that I had this
impression that he he wants to draw like
both the opening choice and the speed at
which he was moving it felt like kind of
body language like let's finish this
game so I was kind of thinking like okay
what to do I decided to play C6 line now
you have to find a way to make a draw is
with
no no I mean I of course like DC4 is the
line I usually Play It's of course
extremely solid but this is more of a
fighting line in fact the thing is that
after like Rook D1 Knight D7 Knight E5
uh black doesn't really have ways to to
continue the game because you shouldn't
I mean if you take on E5 you get a bit
worse mm like there's this kind of I
think well-known line something like
this um and other moves I mean there are
moves here like I think you can play
Rook C8 you can play H6 you can do
various moves but kind of the the
approved way is to do this and then you
repeat moves actually I in this position
I think many years ago I was playing
this position with white pieces a few
times for example I played it against
derer and nanu I played against Mickey
Adams um it's very complicated fight
with two Bishops and black is solid but
I kind of understood that he's of course
not going for this he's going for the
repetition and so for my tournament
situation it's it's a really good result
also yes with black pieces today yeah
it's result is it is it a little bit
strange you know that he really with
white pieces it's better for him to make
a draw yes I mean so how it sounds
really know it's of course this Fay
qualific uh candidate qualification is
makes things really weird um I he even
said after the game like I could have
tried to bully him and uh like let's say
gone all out for a win and then he he's
in a weird situation like maybe he
doesn't even want to win if I do
something wrong but of course I I don't
know his intentions like maybe he he
still wants to win and uh so I anyway I
decided to approach the game like any
game where if I'm playing with the black
pieces uh I'm not I wasn't thinking so
much about his situation like I need to
exploit it but if I'm playing with the
black pieces against top level player
then draw I can't complain exactly and
did he say something after the game yeah
we were discussing um a few of us were
discussing like candidates because of
course Lanier has has a chance it's very
interesting as well other players also
have a chance I mean Wesley clearly has
a chance by raing now uh gash for
example Ari even has an outside chance I
think Arjun I was calculating some
possibilities that Arjun could have a
very good final stretch and maybe
qualify and even by rating spot maybe
Parham makulu has a chance W so there's
uh and in some kind of maybe bizarre
world where like Vincent kimer wins all
his games for the rest of the year even
he could have a chance so it's it's
really a tight race there's a lot of
people potentially with a shot
absolutely but of course let's not
forget that yesterday
anybody in this tournament lost him a
theoretical chance to catch up with you
for the grandest tour points and you won
the grandest Tour to rounds to spare
congratulations fa on that and also
former world champion Gary Kasparov sent
the tweet that tremendous result and so
what do you think about it it's really
hard actually to start celebrating when
you play the tournament still but how do
you approach yeah no now it's of course
a new goal uh to try to win the
tournament it's I have a good chance L
also has a good chance and I think
nobody else has a very realistic chance
I believe I mean of course things could
happen but probably Wesley will make a
draw today Wesley yeah Wesley drew it
drew it was clear for him that uh like
he's trying to take his chance with the
rating spot maybe and he still has a
good chance with the rating spot after
this draw so um Wesley doesn't have any
more games so he's he uh finish the
tournament he can't win the tournament I
mean he can only tie for first if both
of us lose and laner draws here and
loses his last game or something like
that then it would be a tie but um but
generally speaking
um most likely one of us will uh either
share first or um or get clear first you
you play with Richard tomorrow with
white pieces what do you think about it
yeah Richard doesn't have so such a good
event so far yeah he's he's struggling
here uh a lot depends on this game of
course of of lenier because we'll see
how the tournament situation looks he
could win this game but uh I feel like
Maxim has prepared some very sharp stuff
it's clear he's in preparation he
doesn't normally play swov so he played
this um rare move here Knight to E7 this
is actually favorite I think used to be
of Magnus Carlson and to be honest a
long time ago I checked this position
but it's really been a long time and I
don't remember a single thing about it
so F6 uh and Knight F5 and we'll see
what happens because it's super sharp
yeah very interesting game I don't think
think lener will lose because he's such
a stable player and um and generally
speaking unless you unless something
goes wrong white should be in complete
safety here um at the moment it doesn't
look like that
this yeah it's a super sharp of course
it's good for maxim that he's in
preparation because if he weren't in
preparation I would assume that black
would be in serious danger of course
yeah thank you so much Fabby and all the
best of luck for you for the last round
and see you tomorrow thank you thank you
thank you Anastasia thank you Fabby and
let's just refresh everyone's memory
about the fabulous year that Fab's had
yeah it has indeed been fantastic it
started in Romania winning the
competition there and earning
$100,000 and the grand chest Croatia
came forth knitted 20,000 and then at
the World Cup in August he secured his
spot to the 2024 candidates by netting
third place also US champion and just
recently won the St Louis rapid and
Blitz and also 2023 Grand chess tour
champion and maybe still the singfield
Cup champion as well that would mean
that he would be a double winner of the
two classical events in the grand chest
what would you say if you won three
tournaments in a row what's that hat a
trifect yeah hatrick yeah yeah yeah very
very very it's a very fancy world and uh
we've had a short round thus far uh
folks I mean two grandmas draws Joy yes
two grand master draws but they were
done with speed at least Anish giri
Fabiano Carana finishing their game very
quickly as did weso and Yan pomi who
pedal furiously to an opposite kala
Bishop end games that means two games
are remaining between Richard rort and
Le leavon aronian and and lenia
Dominguez who is fighting for first
place he faces off against Maxim bashra
who has uncooked some home preparation
yeah we know that it's still a
theoretical position and uh I think very
much like Fabby just said in his
interview where he has to recall he
hasn't looked at 97 in some time I'm
sure uh for uh lanir he's uh thinking
about those same variations that you've
been describing F2 F3 uh Peter yeah
returning to this for a second it's
interesting that ler after very
confidently getting to this position he
was still I think above his starting
time when he played F6 has now sunk more
than 20 minutes into uh this particular
one decision um apart from you can get
to the position where we're discussing
in two different orders black still has
to take on F6 regardless so you you get
here by either starting with F3 or
starting with castles there is also an
option of playing G2 G4
forcing the Knight away just castling
Queen side putting the Knight on D4 next
move because black can't really Bishop
takes C4 is now a threat due to this uh
x-ray along the D file so we we have
time to play N9 D4 here right the bishop
will drop back to C2 and uh in this in
this position it for some reason the
engine prefers to keep the the king sort
of in the center and plays like check
King B1 Rook G8 and play some kind of
position like this once again my initial
reaction here I would very much like
play this with white yes cuz I really
like this Knight and I really hate this
bishop right but it seems that this has
not really left the the equality margins
all that much it gives white slight
preference but nothing nothing compared
to what I would have guessed see I would
have liked white a lot exactly me too
I'm looking at this position I'm
thinking that D5 Pawn that's
mine wow okay like I mean it feels like
it's so easy right you know you just
Bishop B3 Knight C2 Knight B4 let me
Munch that guy off the board right but
I'm looking at the relative safeties of
the king as well yeah that as well yeah
the King on B1 is just very nice look
and the Knight on H4 isn't making an
impression and it's only it just plays
very slowly it goes Rook E8 it goes for
some reason Rook goes to specifically G6
because it seems like you're putting
yourself in the way of potential xrays
but no it goes It goes uh puts put puts
pieces on these squares maybe The Rook
then goes to F6 to enable Knight F3
maybe is the idea if you pass here with
black and I think the biggest argument
the engine has here is that it takes
quite a long long time to actually
generate an important threat apart from
your plan of Bishop B3 Knight C2 which I
very much like by the way why not I
don't know what else to name there's
also F2 F3 but it feels like F2 F3 will
lead to like Mass simplifications right
because yes this end game is once again
quite Pleasant for white of course you
have the better bishop and so on but but
so much material has come off the board
that the engine appears to be holding it
there there or thereabouts uh so you're
choosing between a very limited number
of things to do it's probably either of3
or or those types of plays and after
Bishop B3 yeah the engine does play Rook
F6 and says I'm now prepared to play
Knight F3 in some situations Knight C2
it's not very afraid of it it just says
I have enough I have enough pieces to
control whatever I need to control uhhuh
and this setup weird I'm still not sure
I guess the whole thing is that the
night coming to F3 there's just no way
we double the it's going to take so many
squares away like it takes away D2 it
takes away D4 right and here you you can
start sort of start seeing an outline of
how black will keep things together it
looks kind of like black has employed
every single piece just not to lose
material in the center but now you will
suddenly start grabbing space you start
denying white anything to do and if em
knows all of this he will be uh I think
quite okay to navigate this but yeah
this is a massive decision I was
wondering what ler is considering I
guess the existence of G4 is probably
the reason why he's been thinking for
some time Peter so I mean whether it's
G4 Castle short or F3 I think he's up to
about 20 25 25 minutes on uh this on
this decision and how about Leon's a CH
chance to play F7 F5 yeah we should
probably invest a solid 15 seconds into
watching he's trying to get it in
the
operation has started I mean take a look
he's put the King on h8 D5 has happened
and uh he's done everything he could
exactly to get in but so uh just to
continue our our expose of how we got
here yes the moment black plays G7 G6
here V very very often immediately uh
challenges the the black kings with H5 H
H2 H4 and this is also the reason for
the Kings still being on E1 I think if
black doesn't play G6 here you probably
still continue making waiting moves you
wait for G6 because you would very much
like to include The Rook on H1 in the
game but Leon says no waiting let's
let's go let's go Bishop G7 H5 G5 this
looks kind of ugly because we've
completely now cut off our own Bishop
from uh from the game everything is on
the dark squares it seems like it's a
very uh useless useless piece but black
will make progress elsewhere uh the KN
drops back because a five cently hasn't
been threatened obviously with the X-ray
along this diagonal but Leon definitely
will playing h8 next and then F7 F5
trying to revive the bishop on G7 will
be a massive idea so this is very
logical Leon played Knight
D7 Richard played Knight D2 C6 I was
wondering if he's intending to play
Queen F3 and trying to stop uh D5 but my
screen is telling me that D5 is such an
important idea here followed by F5 that
Queen F3 wasn't actually even stopping
it and also you can do it in the other
order as
well yeah all of these things and just
to illustrate black gets so much space
in in the center here with E5 E4 like 93
youu include Bishop E6 and then at some
point all of these pawns will start
going going down Downstream uh it really
is unattractive for white to allow this
so reard played uh G4 D5 Bishop B3 and
this is now a position I struggle to to
assess because
black has a very solid Center the bishop
will come out to E6 you are never going
to attack the pawn on D5 enough for
black to have to commit to either D4 or
D Tak D4 would be a horrible actually no
it seems to still be okay but I dislike
it immensely because I really don't want
this bishop 1 B3 to participate in the
game right uh and Leon has played king
h8 for now I would have started with
Bishop B6 but this is completely fine
the big question
is who makes progress here and how okay
I have an idea it just really reminds me
of the old lines in the warl attack you
know Queen E2 in the the Lopez when they
were going Queen E2 and they going H3 G4
and so first of all I would like to go
Queen E2 and then then you know me I'm a
big fan of maneuvering so hang on uh
yeah I was thinking this but I I need to
do it at the right time so Knight F1 KN
let's pretend I don't even look at this
side of the board I'm not going to try
and punish punish whatever you're doing
I am I'm very grateful that you indulged
me yes and that was as far as my plan
okay I'm making some moves some of them
and then a knight jumps into F5 which
one you like H you know the one that's
on G3 yeah okay centralization very my
argument here is that you've achieved
first of all I am not obliged to react
as long as I don't blunder the D5 Pawn
don't blunder the D5 Pawn what what
really I want to say gets my goat here
opening myself up to various things uh
is the the engine actually suggest
something that I would have never I
would never have done here with black
which is take with this bishop and then
also play D5 D4 I just like it it goes
against everything I hold dear in chess
right because we've given up the two
Bishops and we've also made this into a
veritable monster this is now an
absolutely dominant Bishop on the light
squares but it just says I will put the
Knight on F6 you will never ever open
anything up on the king side once these
Knights disappear that's true but you
can switch to the queen side right you
can even castle if you want to although
that may guess I guess we go Queen E7 we
go Knight F6 next so what we end up
doing I mean thinking is unnecessary but
just to illustrate is some kind of
opposition like this where I don't know
we make a couple more moves
and I don't know I don't know if anybody
is opening anything here to be honest
cuz I think C2 C3 and then C takes D4
might be very very counterproductive I
think it just makes Black's position
better and also for black if I just
continue shuffling I don't think B7 B5
does a single thing I'm just never
reacting to this and you're not going to
be threatening B takes A4 it does
nothing you're not threatening B it
feels to me that there is a massive
danger in the structure of neither
neither side really having a Way
Forward
because what I really liked what I also
thought was the only productive plan
white has doesn't appear really to give
you uh very much at all so
it's a it's an interesting position it's
a position it's a structure I've never
really seen before played at the top
level or at least I can't recall seeing
it at the top level but I'm very curious
whether and these are two of the more
creative players in our field for sure
abely so if if if anyone can find a way
something to do here it's those two
right but currently I'm a little bit
struggling to name a plan that actually
provokes a response you know all of
these seems like we're just shuffling
Without Really changing very much Peter
I think that the variation that you just
pointed out especially that Bishop takes
F5 is one of those things that the engin
have taught is that the defensive
resources in a given position are more
than you thought because Bishop takes F5
would never have been on my agenda
either I mean you we're just taught not
to Aid our opponent and give that Bishop
on B3 versus the bishop on G7 there
there is if we return to this position
for a second just to perhaps you know
restore some faith in humanity for our
viewers M G5 is hanging if you if you do
nothing why why does wi win this Central
Pawn so basically by this point if if I
position my pieces differently if I play
Queen D7 here so that after Knight F5 I
can play Rook d8 right I think this is
perfectly okay there is no real call to
take on F5 we're definitely not afraid
of Knight G7 queen king G7 because you
know please trade a good piece for this
porn I will very much welcome you you
know reading me of that you know
quarrelsome Bishop yeah uh
so this is not obligatory but the fact
that it doesn't mind it at all was quite
striking to me I I thought I thought if
we force black to take with the bishop
and then follow it up with D5 D4 in
particular we must be doing something
right right but the king side is so
closed that it appears to be not very
much at all I guess you have to actually
once you've committed to this idea of
changing you have to follow it up with
closing with D4 cuz otherwise Knight G4
is coming and then maybe white even
plays D4 themselves it probably can be
provoked because you can you can still
start with Queen D6 but after Queen F3
really investing all this energy into
not playing D4 it feels like you're not
really doing it right yeah it's still
okayish but I guess just biting the
bullet playing D4 Knight G8 Knight F6
and saying Thou shalt not pass
is uh and uh let's just interrupt
ourselves to jump to Anastasia
who is with Wesley so Anastasia over to
you yes exactly here I'm with Wesley
Wesley the tournament is over for you
right now after this draw against Yan
pishi so what happened today what was
your plan for the game my plan well I'm
not
exactly happy with the way the
tournament has gone and also now that
finished like not exactly totally
pleased with my performance but uh it is
what it is I mean I had a a very tough
day yesterday I had an off day
basically I prepared some lines but I
never expected Fabiano to play The Ether
NSO again against me so I didn't look at
it uh and that's basically the moral
when for me when playing against Fabiano
like it's better just to sleep or watch
a movie or read a book and not prepare
at all because every single time time I
play him for classical I would
prepare like for example on black I
would prepare against one E4 and then he
play D4 or I would prepare against one
D4 and then he play C4 so he just every
time I prepare against Fabiano it ends
up in a disaster so I knew it was going
to happen yesterday like I would prepare
something and he'd play play something
totally surprising that I didn't expect
but uh uh you know I I I didn't stick to
the plan yeah I know this crazy feeling
is when you spend so many hours on prep
and then your opponent play something
completely different yes it was uh it
was much easier a few years ago because
fabbi is primarily an one E4 player and
he would always go one E4 so at least I
kind of know what to expect but uh he's
a really good player and that's a
problem like he can play anything and
also he's got very deep preparation so
it's and also he's a decent he's a very
good chess player so it's makes it
really difficult to prepare against him
that's better not to prepare at all yeah
so you think the let's say yesterday's
game was the most decisive for your
tournament and today it was not so yeah
but I mean to be honest uh Leon aronian
also gave me a free gift in in our game
like he he also blundered by playing C5
in the end game so yesterday I blundered
terribly I mies up the opening like uh I
played the line
which I don't think I've ever played
before yesterday and it's very complex
and I haven't checked it in a few months
so then it's hard really to to to do
something if you if you don't remember
right yeah people say chess is very
drowish and they are right in a way but
it's also there's a lot of lines to to
memorize and when when you mix up with
move your move order and opening you can
can pay very dearly so chess is not as
easy as it looks from the outside not
it's not easy at all don't ask me twice
to repeat this yeah people think oh yeah
draw draw draw equal I think but but I
have actually have to remember quite a
bit in the opening so now with with the
situation let's say you don't play in
the last round so can we a little bit
think of what can happen which scenarios
will will can can be good for you not so
good for you because still probob has to
play tomorrow one more game and same for
linear today he has to play this
position against Maxim and then he has
one more round well again I'm not
very pleased with uh a quick draw today
it's not exactly what I want but uh uh
it is what it is and it's hard to play
your best after a a loss yes so I think
I have really good chances
to or I I think pretty much guaranteed
to finish in the top three in the grand
CH T and Y can correct me if I'm wrong
but uh I think so yes and maybe like the
worst case scenario if you have to play
uh playoff right I don't know if it's
possible no I don't think there's a
playoff because if you look at the Grand
Chester standing I think unless I'm I've
lost my mind I think I'm like
19.7 and uh there's always always hold
this point so there's no there's no
chance of good so we congratulate
already that you achieved your goal I
remember told me before the tournament
that the most important for you is to
make sure you play the next grest tour
okay I'm not a th% sure but I think I'm
pretty confident unless something crazy
happens but lightning doesn't strike
twice at the same place but I mean I of
course it's my priority because uh and
I'd like to thank the opportunity to
thank the organizers and the sponsors of
the grand chest store because I've been
playing in this tournament since I was a
kid you know since 2015 M and every
single year I play in the grandchester
and uh the tournaments are so well
organized it's very
professional and U the players are
really really strong and I love the
format as of the rapid and Blitz uh I
just you know my mom and I love the
grand Chester so it's uh it's really my
goal you know to start qualify every
year and I hope I do exactly my last
question like was this season 2023 in
some way special for you what Memories
you will have this one well it's you
know it's it's another year you know
it's uh great to be back over playing
over the board chess uh after the
pandemic years I wasn't sure things
would go back normal but they seem
pretty much are uh well I played a lot
of tournaments this year uh it's been
not exactly what I expected what I hoped
for in the beginning but uh I had a lot
of fun I I played in y played in
dorf played also very nice uh rapid and
Blitz tournament in Amsterdam the
levitov is one of the best tournaments I
ever played in I played a great Bliss
tournament in Berlin twice uh and yes
yes so I mean it was we had the world
rapid and team yes exactly many events
and we became the world champion also
yeah was the team yes so so it's it's
it's been a it's been a fun it's been a
fun year it's been a lot of uh events
and uh I know I had a I had a great time
you know I love I love playing chess and
uh uh you know I'll do it again a
heartbeat not not exactly doing it for
money but For the Love of the Game and
it's work you know it's a it's a i the
the only thing I hate about Chess is
being stuck in airplanes and airports
like you you kill you kill a lot
of time in your life yeah but but once
you get to the place it's uh it's
wonderful and uh we're grateful to St
Louis for helping me have a career yeah
thank you Wesley so much and all the
best of luck for you in the end of this
year and for the next season yeah maybe
I also have an outside chance of
qualifying for the candidates if I
didn't lose yesterday it would have been
big chance but we'll see what it happens
uh but um yeah it's still open question
at the moment yes all the best of luck
in this two for you yeah for sure thank
you thank you and we are going back to
the studio thank you Anastasia and is
our great pleasure to have with us
grandm Maurice Ashley joining us here in
the studio thanks so much thank you for
being here surprise surprise well you
know there's a big event here I got to
show up just to hang out with you you
all and have a bit of fun wow well
welcome Maurice what I mean it's it's
wonderful having you here at the
singfield cup what you been up to you
know I've been up to quite a few things
with my books that are coming out in a
in a few months an adult book on the
wisdom of Chess that I've gained over
the years we all have learned from this
wonderful game and also a children's
book on my life which is a a book for
early readers both of those are coming
out on April 2nd and they're ready for
pre-order on Amazon so if you want to
check that out April
2 there something Weir funny about that
one yeah somehow that both Publishers
decided to do it on the exact same day
and of course the chess courses I'm
trying to catch up with you yes I'm in
my fourth course now I just finished how
to reassess your chest but Jeremy Silman
as you know he recently passed on so I
had that opportunity to voice that
classic so happy about that so you know
just trying to stay busy all right and
of course watching you all do a fabulous
job on the show and obviously we're at
the sinkfield Cup Final Tournament of
the grand chest T have you been
following I have I have I've been
watching all of you do a masterful job
Peter handling the big
board with with Incredible finesse
sight as always so yes it's absolutely B
an interesting blow up in the last
couple of rounds all heck broke loose
and people started bashing each other
which was cool to see of course today's
draws don't seem so exciting a little
distasteful on two of the games th far
they happened in under underneath an
hour and less than an hour game was
games were okay well everything there's
so much at stake right there's the
candidate spots I mean have you been
following the race there you know with
circuit and the fre day ratings I mean
what are your thoughts on that I think
it's crazy I mean it's wild the the the
rating issue is of course always with
controversy who's not played enough and
and the like um but it's still fun to I
mean it looks like chess is just boring
to have controversy it's what we do
right there's always something going on
and and so it's fun to see it's crazy to
think that four Americans might get into
the candidates that's absolutely insane
the came out of nowhere why is this guy
he never loses to the SFI cup what's up
with that I know is an elite tournament
all the best plays in the world oh but I
never lose I mean what is that about
that's incredible he's just been a beast
so far absolutely wow well here we are
uh Maurice we might even be seeing a
third um Grandmaster draw this one is
less not this one I meant uh leavon
sorry I meant not leav
against they've been repeating I believe
well the draw offer is on the table here
I really feel like switching the camera
away from Maurice is a is a crime
against humanity let's put chest pieces
on the board here for a second we've
already had this repetition once and ler
is clearly now considering whether he
should be playing Rook F2 he is now down
to 50 minutes uh against somebody who is
very very obviously uh had this on their
screen today Rook F2 is playable as we
we discussed it's maybe even a little
bit better for why but the positions are
quite sharp ler is tied for first Fabi
has already drawn his game so King H1
wouldn't be a horrible practical
decision for us as you know viewers of
the tournament we would very much like
Rook F2 here right but you you wouldn't
really you know blame him very much if
he if he decides to go King H1 and this
one also disappears off our screens of
course we would blame him we want to see
blood talking about what about the
million dooll open no draws you got to
play for the win yeah these they're so
good everyone's so good actually this
morning I just came in yesterday and
miraculously had a chance to have
breakfast with Maxim this morning okay
and we were chatting about different
things statistics being one of them we
know he's a ma mathematician and it
looks like repetition is taking place
sadly uh and and I asked I said Maxim
you know what's the deal why when are
you going to back score a win yeah when
are you going to be back period like
it's it's you I'm not used to seeing Max
see him drop out of the top 10 the way
he has like a rock you we see this
repetition taking place his typical
French mauce mace I I I must play
better
yeah that's one of the things you got to
do yeah just do it already and you know
we we've not seen him show his best but
of course he's one of the best prepared
players and as Peter said we can't blame
him if lanir says not this one this guy
this guy looks like he knows what he's
doing right well we do see on the camera
Maxim thinking hard he looks like he
might be considering the Alternatives
but I'm not an expert on body language
and uh Maurice when it comes to the
stats you you mentioned you know that
you were discussing stats I mean we've
come up with some stats our resident uh
stat decision Ben and came up with some
very interesting stats
about like there being 48 point was it
close to 50% decisive games the
originator all those things
talkinging to the choir I know but were
you surprised by how things like turned
out you know statistics has been
something as Yas knows he and I have
talked about it quite a bit
unfortunately sadly Yasser is a Dallas
Cowboy fan so
peace blessings to the Dallas Cowboys
for all the joy that they bring to their
yeah I'm a New York Giants fan as he
knows so the opportunity to needle me
he's not going to lose that given how
badly we're doing it they're doing a
little bit better understandings but
nevertheless we know that watching
sports stats are a huge part of it
analytics as transformed basketball
without any question about it it used to
be pound you know in the in the paint
now players are shooting threes like
it's going out of style and the
transformation is from the numbers and
chess I mean it's really an anal itical
game that's what we do and there are
numbers hiding in plain sight that we
have not explored fully enough I think
given all the data we have so it's cool
to be able to work with somebody like
young Ben Underwood who for me it's like
I'm a kid in a candy store talking to
him and asking him about the various
stats the move counts the the averages
and the like and there's some surprising
things that have come out of it for
example when when I remember you were
asked about early rounds or later rounds
penultimate penultimate was yeah the
fight's taking place at the end this is
the penultimate what we're seeing right
now the penultimate this is what's
happened this is what the stats say this
is what happens in the later rounds
players are more inclined to draws and
your intuition is one thing but Peter
you you mentioned I remember you you
being stunned by a a couple of stats as
well but let me show you you see this
dat there's a new uh about which rounds
are the most decisive oh here we go
singfield upset sorry this is a new one
let's go okay the most significant
upsets
by black over white oh Magnus Caron
losing nean remember that not sure it
counts officially anymore the largest
white over black second Carlson versus
Kon 76 rating points is the largest
upset with the black pieces outside of
the Newan game right and the lowest Fay
rating to win a game was darush versus
Jeffrey I'm that's that I think this
interesting stat between Carlon and
carolana I think that's the case because
usually there's not a significant rating
difference between the players because
very few I mean it's usually the top
players in the tournament that are
invited so the Gap is smaller so that 76
which would seem somewhat surprising in
an open tournament for example would be
stunning in an open tournament is not so
surprising here for me when we were
talking about stats and as we were
coming into the very very first
broadcast we have the zoom call with you
Maurice and you were saying that you and
Ben had done this you know detailed look
at some of the stats for me one of the
things that you pulled out which was a
real gem was one lanir Dominguez nobody
beat lanir right didn't see that coming
at all that's like yeah so we should be
doing more analytics with the Chess
World it's just it it lend itself
perfectly it's in its infancy now as you
start making these comparisons the
players themselves could benefit one of
the things that I found stunning I
believe it was a Wesley that that said
he's the worst performer in the second
half of the tournament on the tour right
wouldn't guess that I don't want to get
pointed out as the worst performer put
the finger on that guy why you show but
it's kind of interesting you know if
you're doing well at the beginning but
you're not performing later what are the
reasons for that or even things like
long games Peter fidler uh Yan I mean
pet Peter you pointed out that the stat
when Yan was the one who performed who
won his games in the longest time now to
me when you think Yan puni that's fire
and brimstone going you know all kinds
of craziness on the board tactics he
must be winning games quickly how was y
the one 65 move average 65 moves y the
sh you you would have had me guess 10
players and he would have been number 10
maybe ala would have been number 10 but
not not Yan those are ala was actually
at the top so with ala you would have
been completely correct but Yan yeah
it's a very counterintuitive stud there
and as I mentioned I I think people
underestimate if we talk about Yan just
how good of a technical player he is and
how much he enjoys winning slightly
better positions just by being more
precise over a long
stretch but this but this whole stat
that is like a well uh a a rich vein to
dig and to get these uh Reon you know
and think about that as a player think
about as a player not just as
commentators and fans but think about it
as a player if you say oh it's nepo he's
a fighter he you know fire and brimstone
keep the game calm let's let's go into
an end game and then the stat says dude
wins all the end games what whoa whoa
whoa whoa wait a second that may not be
what we want to do that's not the key to
beating him right so that's where I
think strategically you can start
integrating statistical analysis with
with performance and that's what we care
about I don't care what you understand
in chess I don't care what you know how
do you perform that's what we really
want to know and and how do we perform
individually as players if we've done a
statistical analysis on your own games
what what do they show they might show
something surprising yeah I would love
to see that right you know just to have
uh some data on whether I do well on
closed positions open positions the
bishop the Knight you know because we
have certain assumptions about our play
but the stats will prove otherwise I was
stunned looking at my games I used to
think I was such a tactician I always
wanted to attack and when I reviewed my
games long long retired and looking up
my games I was like this guy is boring
who is this guy he's trading off the
game in the game I was looking at all
the crazy variations then I play the
solid move what so a lot to be seen from
real analysis I I remember my own case
it was pretty uh funny I'm going to play
a match here in St Louis against anat
CaRu holy smokes you're going to play
one of the world's greatest players ever
anatol carbuff you're going to take it
seriously so I did this uh openings uh
search what am I going to play against
anator I know he's going to play D4 I
got a problem I'm gonna play D4 I want
to surprise him I'm G to play the Dutch
scores
72% tear that one up okay I'm going to
surprise him I'm going to play
this and it turned out the SLO defense
and I chose the SLO defense because uh
sorry Jo you want to say by the way you
know the players have repeated three
times third grandmas draw out of three
games and statistics say round round
eight one of the dud rounds but that was
funny but let's talk about that for just
a moment because it was round one was
the most exciting and seven out of the
nine winners of round one won the SFO
cup all draws second round statistically
speaking was the most decisive all draws
again all draw again three in a row uh
we were at 0 Z and now we're at 25%
coming into today yeah not not anymore
not anymore 25% Al I should if there's a
decisive result in the last one we're
still at 25% after that but it it it
seems so we started underwhelming uh
underwhelming with all of these draws
but 25% is probably an average for the
singfield cup is that right that's it
depends on the round yeah overall the
overall tournament yes the challenge
with an event like this and for I think
it's a question even for the grand chess
tour maybe an existential question is
when you have all these strong players
playing classical chess
exactly pretty good and in the age of
engines that show openings to raise your
thin margins you're not getting an edge
black is perfectly fine everywhere you
look is this the right design even is is
a question we have to ask because yes
you get the best chess so to speak you
get the most accurate chess but are you
getting the most entertaining show
necessarily and and there's some
tournaments that combine top players
with lower rated players i' love to hear
Peter chime in on this what do you think
I mean you look at a tournament coming
up like Tata steel and it's always
belligerent I mean there's blood on the
board because the top players are going
okay wait a minute there's a point
there's a point there's a point and and
and it just creates an Ambiance for
ferocity uh and aggression is this
necessarily the ideal way to go for us
we just had the contrast we had the St
Louis rapid and Blitz prior to the S
phield cup which had a huge number of
decisive and belligerency Maurice we're
going to be going to a break but thank
you so much for uh coming on the show I
mean it's nice to have you around it's
really really really great to see
youin his books send out your likes
absolutely and uh well we are going to
take a very short break but don't go
anywhere because we are going to be back
with more of the chess action between
Richard report and leevon aronian so
don't go
[Music]
anywhere it's a pleasure to sit first
all with you Tony here because I know
that with single cup is coming just
nearby and you are so busy with many
things so thank you for coming first of
all and now that we are celebrating the
10th anniversary of singfield cup um I
mean it's important to kind of make sure
acknowledge the the role which you
played in this tournament and um let's
say your passion to Chas your
organizational skills made it clear that
this tournament has high standards so
how can you reflect on this journey with
singfield cup over those 10 years Wow
first of all uh I found out that it was
our 10-year anniversary of the sing
field cup just a couple of days ago I
can't believe it's been that long
honestly I still remember that very
first event with just four players we
had Magnus and leavon aronian against
gakamsky and hikaro
Nakamura and and for for me watching all
of these great players come to St Louis
growing the event from four players that
year to six the following year into 10
players making the singfield cup a part
of the grand chess tour um you know I
think I'm most proud of the fact that
this his legacy building for the St
Louis chess club what the the singfield
cup has done for St Louis is establish
it in the Chess World um throughout
history absolutely but let's start from
the very beginning how how it was
actually done how the first one appeared
and what was the inspiration for the
first singfield cup the first singfield
cup we owe a debt of gratitude actually
to seil we manry uh seil is a chess
coach himself also known as The
Stepfather of hikara Nakamura um seil
has been great partner with the St Louis
chess club over the years and he was
traveling to a chess tournament where
both Magnus and leavon would be playing
um we reached out to seil and said hey
we would love to get these guys to play
in our our first singfield cup uh at the
time the name wasn't even the singfield
cup and so uh seil while he was over
there had the opportunity to chat with
both players and secure their commitment
to play so that I would say is how the
first singfield cup came to be wow this
really interesting I mean I'm sure many
people don't even remember how it all
this happened and how do you see the
tournament grown all these years from
that event the first one until the one
we have today T singfield cup looking
through all of the singfield cups it's
interesting from the perspective of the
broadcast the Arbiters commentators the
the crew that puts the event on social
media coverage everything has changed
about how we produce an event like the
singfield cup you know in those early
days it would just be a couple of
commentators in the basement of the
chess Club a couple of camera operators
capturing all of the the footage from
both the playing Hall and in the studio
itself um you know and there were some
hiccups in those early days I remember
when the stream would go down and
everybody would be running around trying
to figure out how to make it come back
up uh I would say that that not just the
professionalism for the chess players
and and that side of the event uh have
improved over the 10 years but I would
say what the club has really done well
has set the bar for chess broadcasting
and chess um coverage exactly and also
we know that single cup is a part of the
grunch tour the big you know the big
tour and what role it plays in the whole
Grand chest tour and from which moment
actually it became the part of it the
grand chest tour started in 2015
actually it was a partnership between
the St Louis chess club uh the London
chess classic and uh our friends at
Norway chess as well um so there were
three classical events that first year
no rapid no Blitz um the singfield cup
is the one event that has been the main
stay throughout the entire Grand chest
tour over its um Bo eight years I guess
now uh so the singfield cup to me
represents um kind of the bookend of the
grand chess tour season it's a classical
tournament that brings together all of
the very best players in the world um
and the players already know what their
standings are from the rest of the grand
chest tour they know what they're coming
into this and they know how hard they
have to fight and I think that produces
some very exciting chess in the
sinkfield cup absolutely uh as a
technical director of the tournament for
so many years which challenges you had
during all these years can you tell some
interesting stories and some challenges
which you had and you had to solve and
you soled successfully I could write a
book on the challenges that we have
faced uh organizing major events like
these things you wouldn't consider
geopolitics the closing of canals um
delayed flights and weather in Norway
can impact a chess tournament in St
Louis I remember spending uh very late
nights and very early mornings on the
phone with the US state department and
embassies and consulates around the
world trying to help players get their
visas in fact I remember one story
specifically I was with Yan napesi
trying to obtain a visa to come to St
Louis the US Embassy was delaying and
and he didn't have time on his own so I
went with him in person to the US
Embassy in Croatia to try to obtain his
Visa unfortunately we weren't successful
that time but I learned about a lot
about the Visa process absolutely I can
imagine you know I've been through this
process also
many times but thanks God I mean players
are here and singfield cup number 10 is
next to the corner on the next corner so
what are you expecting from this one
this year singfield cup I think will be
one of the most exciting because it has
some really interesting players in it
guys like Richard bror um Yan Duda these
are some players that have that are
right on that threshold you know we we
see the Magnus Carlson's the leavon
aronian the Lena dominguez's these are
players that have been established in
the top 10 and have won major events
themselves outright many times I think
this is a really exciting time for chess
because we still have those established
players and at the same time we have
these upstarts that are really coming
into their own so I think this year
singfield cup promises to be a blood
bath across the board um absolutely but
what about the most exciting singfield
cup for you personally which one was the
most memorable so there was a year that
Vish andan played the singfield cup uh
and I don't remember exactly which year
it was but driving into work that that
morning uh I was driving just past the
front of the chess club and I saw VI
Anan walking into the Starbucks I have
to admit I almost crashed my car I was
so excited I'm like it's vishy it's
vishy I had to calm down and realize yep
yep he's going to play a chess
tournament here pretty soon um so that
was really
exciting this is funny story uh probably
the most exciting singfield cup for me
would have been the one uh I think it
was 2017 where Fabiano went 7 and0 in
the first seven rounds I mean watching
that performance and calculating the ODS
of him doing it again and is he going to
make it in round five and is he going to
win in round six and Will he win in
round seven the excitement building was
was really memorable I wonder who were
all these people who were working behind
the scenes all those years can you name
maybe not all of them but those who
survived for for 10 years I think we
might have to roll the credits if I'm
going to name everybody because it's
going to be a long long list I say this
at the opening ceremonies a lot to the
players they have a lot of contact with
myself or maybe with Rebecca who's our
event manager
um Kelly tol who handles travel and
hotels for the players but they don't
have a lot of interaction with with the
rest of the staff literally dozens of
people who make these events possible
from the front desk staff at the chess
club who answer the phone and sell
tickets and make sure that guests and
members have access to the commentary to
the folks that actually produce the
events the Kevin Duggins the Brian Adams
Marcus baton that are behind those
cameras that are configuring the devices
and making them happen Eric arson who
makes sure that the website and the
technology is working properly Leonard
Otis who makes sure the dgt technology
works it literally does take a village
to produce these event and we're really
lucky to have a great team exactly so my
last question like what do you think is
the impact of a sful cup for on the
history of Chess and the popularity of
Chess I think the impact the singfield
cup has on the history of Chess is um
still being made I think what we're
doing in St Louis is producing great
quality events we've done it for 15
years and I look forward to doing it for
the next 15 that's a great um that's a
great comment I mean Tony all the best
of luck in this and all the best for the
singfield cup which is coming tomorrow
thank you very much thank
[Music]
you welcome back to sful cup I'm here
with ler Domingos the game finished in
the draw the third game already of round
eight is over um what happened today I
think it was also preparation from your
opponent which yeah I was a bit
surprised by this line it's not very
common and um yeah he seemed extremely
well well prepared I think um I more or
less remember that this was possible but
uh yeah after um we went for this whole
line with it takes F5 E4 F6
Knight F5 already I was uh kind of
trying to to find out what to do um so
F3 it's a very forcing move yeah um I
was considering Knight D4 but um it was
clear that after something like takes
takes and queen F6 black should be fine
uh there's also Queen A5 check on top of
this I got the CD also Queen A5 forcing
white to move the king and it doesn't
look very good like after King F1 maybe
long Castle or something like that so um
I had to play F3 uh Queen F6 and yeah uh
I guess F4 was possible Queen H4
G3 Knight takes G3 Queen F2 and he takes
C4 uh probably this is what he has
prepared look Thro to me probably is
Bishop B5 check kind of force takes and
queen G3 and then takes takes Rook G8
something like this um yeah yeah also
didn't seem too promising so Castle is
logical and after Queen B6 yeah King H1
I was thinking that Knight D6 uh was the
move I didn't see um the I mean this uh
Queen H6 move um and I was trying to
find out what was this position after
for example Knight D4 long Castle Bishop
C2 um I thought the bishop C2 are not to
take because I don't know it seemed
dangerous to me to open the B7 Bishop
and then there can be ideas with Rook G8
at some point pressure on G2 but after
Bishop C2 um black will play something
like Rook E8
anyway and yeah I wasn't sure how to
evaluate this type of position but yeah
Queen H6 is probably very precise um I
have to come back to G1 and after Queen
B6 I guess if I want to play for a win I
need to play the move Rook F2 and then
we get a very similar position after
Knight D6 Knight D4 castle and then I
don't know if takes or or Bishop C2
immediately something like this and Rook
E8 again I wasn't sure how to evaluate
and it looked double edge to me um he
seemed very well prepared I already
spent some time and um decided to to
play solid yeah to uh go for a door in
fact he he he I think he he can even
play on after Queen H6 King E1 for
example Knight D6 but then Knight D4
yeah again we get same type of thing but
with the queen on H6
he can try to go like Rook G8 and and um
I will play A4 I mean h yeah it could be
really sharp it looks that black I mean
white should be doing well here but uh
yeah I wasn't sure I mean this is maybe
also possible so yeah he was well
prepared what can I say yeah yeah
absolutely and uh Fabi was also here and
he told me that the position is very
sharp and very unclear and he was
definitely worried how the things will
go so what do you think about the
tournament situation now we know know
that he also made a draw you have the
same amount of points tomorrow is the
last round yeah well no in general um
and happy to to to to be in in this
position and to be able to fight for a
first place of course the last round
will be crucial um um are you you
playing with Leonor play against Leon uh
but uh yeah it's uh of course tough game
but uh it's normal in this tournament so
yeah I'll try to play well uh I think in
a way it's also nice to have some time
because the tournament it's already
advanced and uh it takes a lot of energy
so for me it's good to have a kind of
half of a rest day so you can prepare
yeah you can rest a bit and and prepar
but yeah uh overall I think it's it's
been a it's been a great event for me
yeah that's great thank you so much l
all the best of luck tomorrow and we are
going back to the studio thank you
Anastasia and we're join joined in the
studio by Brian Woods who is the music
director creative in Residence of the
World Chess Hall of a Fame and you're
here to tell us all about the World
Chess Hall of Fame music series but
before we do that we're going to go to
Peter who's going to update us on the
one game remaining just a brief update
on this after King h8 yanas mov NF1 has
been played and we were when we were
discussing it between ourselves I
allowed white to do everything they
wanted Leon said no I will actually try
to work against your plans Queen A5
check was played provoking Queen D2 and
here leevon chose to get the Queens off
the board and play Rook d8 so the
position has dried out even more but
honestly without Queens I like this a
little bit more for wife because I think
you can take more Liberties in the
center and perhaps on the queen side
move like F2 F3 to prevent problems with
d Tak C4 and then Knight G3 and perhaps
we start pushing on the queen side but
still fairly fairly balanced a lot of
play ahead and let's go back to Brian
and talk talk about music which always
sounds like a good idea definitely a
good ide idea and Brian tell us about
the the World Chess Hall of Fame music
series of course well I run all the
classical programming at the world chest
Hall of Fame so what I do is I partner
with people from the St Louis Symphony
from Opera Theater St Louis
internationally renowned soloists who
come in and perform on our monthly
series I partner with Brian Owens who
you had earlier in the tournament to put
on this incredible music series that we
have I could not be prouder of the work
that we're doing the level of
musicianship and the collab operations
that we're doing I mean yaser I have to
brag on you a little bit because this
this month I mean we put on a show all
about um Serge bofi David oyster Rock
their famous chess match that took place
and the music that was inspired by the
chess and I mean the the chat that you
gave us the pre-concert talk all about
how pv's chess game had a bearing on his
artistic output was just such an
incredible thing to hear and see and and
you know I was privileged to play with
the assistant concert Master of the St
Louis Symphony and give a a fantastic
show I mean those kinds of
collaborations you're not going to find
anywhere else I'm very I'm very proud of
that that was fun at the world just all
of fam that was a very special evening
and the lady that performed with you
that night yes Hannah G was her name wow
she was terrific wow you're going to be
hosting the Gaya along with your cohort
and cry Bri yes I know my partner in
cryan the other Brian I always say you
can just shout the name Brian somewhere
on the chess campus and someone will
turn their head you know there's plenty
of us but U we're so looking forward to
this on December 2nd um not only are we
the MC's for the evening but we're going
to be performing um celebrating just all
the cultural impact that chess has not
just in St Louis but but everywhere I
mean between musical theater and pop
music I'll be playing a set of classical
music just a an incredible evening in
support of the uh the public programming
that we do as well as the educational
programming but like I said just a
celebration of Chess and everything that
it relates to in culture and of course
it's our Gaya where we have the side
silent
option is open open get out the bids I
know get the bids going everyone it's
not going to be open forever there you
go and I always encourage folks just to
check out the incredible offerings we
have on that silent auction um I was
very privileged to donate a private
concert to the um silent auction as I
think Brian Owens also donated a private
concert along with season tickets which
we're very excited about for our 2024
season which has been announced let me
brag on you for just a moment mind cuz
we've got some uh performance of you we
uh yeah we're going to show that yeah
we're we were very very pleased to here
we
[Music]
go
where you're really into the music
what's going on right there what is
going on right there I I I think there's
a combination of you know I'm up there
to to do a job technically and so
there's a considerations of of what's
happening at the instrument adjusting to
maybe things that don't always go the
same way every single time but there's
also a message to communicate and music
is all about connecting with other
people and telling a story and so I
think in that sense you also have that
responsibility to project a story um
towards folks and you know I always say
and maybe people think I'm wrong here
but I I think there's so many overlaps
between chess and music just because
there's um it's this idea of just
creativity in a structure you know
there's only there's limitations to you
know the boundaries of what are
available for us to do but there's
infinite possibilities and so between
you know I always feel such a
partnership between chess and live music
in that sense I see that and I see such
emotion me too and I was going to ask
you um do you have to strive for
Perfection when you're playing these
yes there a lot of work we strive for
goodness Perfection is
a I mean do you have to be no perfect
because obviously a con you would love
to be you know and things happen every
time you perform that you know it's
never perfect but it's a it's a lifelong
pursuit of of that uh I call it I would
say Excellence perhaps as the the
pursuit of um and it's not just like I
said it's not just the technical it's
also the more you can achieve
technically and the more you have a
Mastery over the instrument the better
you're able to tell that story and
connect with folks in the music so it's
a it's a both and in that situation I
would say I I love that answer and uh
we're speaking about the future what is
in store for the 2024 World Chess Hall
of Fame music series I'm so excited for
this we have so many collaborations like
I said with the St Louis Symphony with
Opera Theater St Louis with win Opera we
have artists coming from out of town we
have some of the best artists in St
Louis um I myself am performing a couple
times which I'm happy to do and uh but
again it's it's the it's the idea of
collaboration that I'm always so excited
about it's the sense of we don't exist
on our own you know there's so much
music around us that we can feature and
and promote and enjoy together and I
just love having that platform um at the
witch off music series and um our season
tickets are available now you can check
that out on worldest hof.com yeah oh
thank you so much Brian joining us thank
you for me and we're looking forward to
seeing you mcing at oh Yesa we're we're
going to regil you with all kinds of
things promise holding a YouTube all
right I'll see you there yeah Ryan keep
up the search for excellence thank you
very much thanks for having me great to
have you on show let's take a look at
our results so far Jo absolutely it's a
short one so far Anish giri ending in a
quick draw against Fabiana Carana and
Lena Dominguez also drawing against
Maxim vasra where so Yan pomi well they
were on the highway to an opposite color
Bishop ending on the highway they sped
right along didn't they they did that
means there is one game remaining and uh
Peter tell us all about that one game
let me do the same speech again because
they haven't really moved from here this
is still the same position with the
Queens coming off as we mentioned uh the
last move that leevon played here Rook
d8 creates this idea of D Tak C4 using
the the pong the D3 uh Pawn the two main
choices here structurally appear to be
you can play F3 to make sure nothing
ever happens to a structure ever again
or you can make a natural looking move
Knight G3 which does allow black once
again using the fact that this is not a
legal move right this moment uh it does
allow black to break free a little bit
by taking on e4 playing F5 but even in
this position you still still uh stuck
with this bishop on G7 which isn't all
that good uh it's a much sharper
position than the one we have on the
board I think we would as viewers we
would like for this to be the
continuation because this I think has
the biggest Prospect of actually uh
evolving into a sharper sharper fight
but it's still reasonably balanced black
has the advantage of the two Bishops the
structure is E5 is maybe a bit
vulnerable in some future but not
immediately no uh but bringing this
bishop into into the game will be a
challenging task it's not quite clear
where it's going to uh play uh well and
uh feels like white is still reasonably
well in control with this very strong
Knight on e4 or as I mentioned you can
play F3 or you can also play King C1
which I don't quite understand the
engine does seem to think that King C1
is for instance stronger than King E2
which is incredibly counterintuitive to
my eyes I don't know why I would have
chosen chosen King C1 here over the very
very natural E2 Square uh or F3 all of
which preserve the structure as is uh
one thing I noticed I don't know exactly
how to demonstrate this idea but one
thing I noticed the engine trying was in
some position like this let's make a
kind of a really strange waiting move in
some positions it was playing C4 not
here though but there was definitely a
moment where I noticed this new idea
being introduced and I think this is
only because the Queens have come off I
think with the Queens on the board you
don't really ruin your position this way
but but but with the Queens coming off
it seems to think that obviously this is
quite good uh still doesn't change the
equilibrium all that much but we'
managed to open some things maybe we'll
get to play Rook hb1 play B2 B4 we do
need scope for our pieces to play right
uh G takes C4 G takes C4 we would very
much like to be able to play C4 C5
perhaps black even needs to play C5
themselves but then we have an
additional Square for all of our Knights
and if I close down and if you go D4 and
if you go D4 once again I want to play
Knight F5 and I want to hope maybe but I
think for for that to work I think I
need to make different moves with black
because here in particular my one idea
of C4 C5 with a is just not going to
work and then black is completely fine
and if black were to just to go C5
immediately I mean isn't that as blocked
as oh the night you have you have to
take on F5 first so have you have to
choose what to take with I am I think in
every single case recapturing this way
to have this very beautiful Square on e4
it might not be enough for an edge
anyway because of how close down
everything is but it's going to be a
very very beautiful horse there on on
the4 Square uh all of this is very
theoretical though
because uh Richard somewhat surprisingly
has been uh thinking here for a good
solid I think 20 minutes maybe already
mhm and the choices are as I presented
you can allow you tak4 you can keep
things in place uh shall we have some
fun and predict
what rich is going to I'm thinking draw
but uh no
nove no not the F3 F3 King E2 I'm going
to go King E2 as well yeah but I'm
thinking what if black just doesn't play
ball he just keeps his Pawn on D5
exactly I'm not sure how we're making
progress if let's say after whatever we
do just goes A5 bishop6 yeah not not F4
yeah yeah not F4 goes King G8 goes I
don't know Bishop B6 and just keeps the
shape per the bishop goes to fa just to
put it on a slightly better Square yeah
I'm struggling to to come up with a
consistent plan that excites me here for
white to be to be entirely honest maybe
maybe it exists but I I don't know what
it is and on a more personal note I just
wanted to say I got a message maybe half
an hour before the round from a good
friend of mine uh who's been watching
some shows but not the others and he
said and I quote literally I apologize
for the first coming forthcoming
snoozefest I will not be able to watch
today shabir we see you don't do that
again right it's his fault it is it is
absolutely his fault We like I I've I've
that's it yeah we figured out who to
blame today 9 G3 by the way I I did
mention I thought I should take 9 G3
just to be a contrarian uh Richard
actually goes with 9 G3 okay which is a
happy occurrence because Leon is also
having a bit of a May tournament I think
he will prob jump at the opportunity to
change something in the structure you
know
really and uh let's check out the
lifetime scores between these two In
classical chess and here are the head-to
heads wow two wins for Richard against
leavon aronian won but six draws this
was one of those where I thought because
of the creativity Factor we would see
more decisive games than draws but draws
is definitely a 2 to1 uh ratio in favor
of draws between these so you think
being an Arbiter is cool well get out
the beeswax yeah I was going to say oh
that's missing is the white gloves from
snooka I have not been able to shake
that image thanks to you guys that
Arbiter should be dressed in the full
black tie Tu and of course Chris bird is
doing the honors there as preparing for
the ultimate round you want to make sure
you have a you know you you got to bend
the Curve I think I've ever play have
you ever played a tournament where an
Arbiter does that kind of housekeeping
well
no first of all but I do appreciate all
of the chess club presidents who come to
the clubs early and they put the pieces
out nicely the score sheets and
everything they're the unsung heroes um
three professional draws and it's a bit
disturbing because we' come on and we
said of the four games the three games
that had the most Intrigue in terms of
candidacy playing for first were those
uh games that were all drawn Peter
that's yeah you can you can make an
argument I think it's actually
convincing argument it's just not a very
happy one that those were those were the
the highest Stakes right and they
players were the much more influenced by
other considerations compared to the
game between Richie and leevon where
players who aren't really in running for
anything apart from a victory on this in
this one game really uh so it's much
more an obvious choice for them to just
continue playing whereas for for our
Nish
and yeah we're being we're being trolled
by the production here
right oh look at that these are a
predictions some people got it more
right than
others I'm going to leave it that we'll
leave that
alone but I did put a quiz I put osed a
quiz uh to uh Peter uh during our break
and the quiz was uh we do have uh wild
cards yeah and we on the grand chest
tour in the past we've invited Magnus
Carlson to be a wild card and Magnus has
won uh one of the rapid and Blitz events
that he was in a wild card has a wild
card player ever won one of the
classical and I'm thinking specifically
Bucharest in singfield because of L
I don't know if he was a wild card when
he won I don't think he he generally
doesn't I think get wild cards to
classical events that would that would
be my feeling he when he doesn't play
the full tour he tends to just show up
for the rapid and Blitz and
windows but uh nothing else to do for
the week yeah my my my feeling is the
answer is no I'm not 100%
certain yeah when we're being now told
by the research Department that no wild
card has never won won a classical event
on the tour right I have a feeling that
maybe apart from Magnus there was
definitely an event where I want to say
Anton coru was leading with one day to
spare maybe in Len okay but he did not
end up winning so in the rapid and Blitz
events I have a feeling that people have
at least done very well maybe nobody
apart from Magnus one the people have
definitely done extremely well right uh
but classical no classical an
outstanding uh result from a linear
Dominguez again a wild card player if he
does if he does end winning too uh what
he's done through eight rounds has been
uh historically and uh not worthy uh Joy
uh one of the topics of discussion has
been the candidates and qualifying and
tell a source of great
excitement I mean who will Who Won't who
will qualify and this is the rules on
the FED circuit elig eligibility and
there you can see a f rated individual
standard tournament is eligible for the
circuit if it meets the following
criteria must finish in the 2023
calendar year and has at least eight
players and has at least seven rounds
three rounds for knockout defense so
Peter to jump in on that I have a
feeling the graphic will continue but if
it if it doesn't which there is there is
there is the part two and the high eight
highest rated players have an average
standard rating of at least 2550
at the start of the tournament I was
thinking specifically about a Swiss so
for a Swiss to qualify it needs some be
eligible it has to be a very strong got
you got at least three National
federations is the the the fifth point
also a requirement and not more than
half of the field has to represent one
Federation so if you're organizing
something let's say in the United States
of America and it's let's say an eight
round round robin there cannot be more
than four Americans in the field got and
the reason we're bringing all of this up
it's not just you know an Excursion into
the very obscure feed day regulations
which are which we are quoting for you
here it is to do with the fact that
let's say we imagine a scenario where
Wesley wins the circuit spot okay uh and
then it goes back to the rating it goes
back to the rating and for the rating uh
lineer will then potentially be in the
lead fantastic but he doesn't have
enough qualifying classical tournaments
played
so if he actually finds himself in that
spot he will need to search for a
tournament he has in December right
which he will have to do well in because
he still has not to lose rating in it
but also the tournament needs to be
eligible under these very very precise
conditions and uh it's not going to be
an easy an easy search for him I would
feel it's it's not uh uh such an obvious
uh set of criteria to right Jo we were
talking about that you I was saying
hello London London
Calling The London chess classic is back
in yeah you know then could get himself
a Concord what a Pity that they've
stopped run London their the red eyee
yeah yeah the Redeye flight London
Calling because this man I mean he has
he's worked in the past with Fabiano he
has been always in the top he's been a
regular the grand
chestor but as far as I recall I don't
think he's qualified himself for a
candidat it would be very nice to see
him for his career having that
achievement yeah I I would love to see
that i' we've been friends for for many
many years we played for the same Club
he played actually for my St Petersburg
club for a number of years which led to
very interesting team meetings because
it's generally like only only he doesn't
doesn't speak the language in most te
meting but he would just sit there very
I would translate some jokes for him if
some funny jokes were available for
translation many of them
aren't and yeah he he added to the team
perfectly somehow despite him not not
really being yeah there was there was a
very clear language barrier there he's
an ultimate professional extremely uh
you know very very diligent very good at
the board that was the Russian chess
League that your yeah the the Club
Championship yeah he's played for the
the bronze horsemen for many a year
well so once again it would appear to my
eyes that Wesley is in that position to
take the Grand Prix potentially and it
would appear that
laner could
easily by the rating but he needs that
requirement activity requ F circuit it's
important that Wesley finishes first
which he cannot do because he's not
playing
tomorrow and I thought he had to finish
equal second ah if he finishes third as
far as I
understand always open to interpretation
I'm not a th% sure if he finishes
outright third he does not overtake
Anish giri in the Fay circuit
gotcha so then he would be taking the
rating position and then you would
assume he is taking the racing position
that once again is contingent on nobody
overtaking him and lineer is now within
touching distance so uh this is all
still up in the air but that really
really uh uh striking situation where we
had this potential for four American
players to to be in the Canada seems to
be receding a little bit because of how
things are secured of course Bobby and
hikaro secure we're talking about W
Wesley might not be secure because if
Lena does find himself that tournament
to play in in December and Chris is
working hard I got to tell you I mean he
takes advantage of these early draws
Onan sorry what you say I was just going
to say if leavon loses to lenia tomorrow
then Lena will overtake Wesley in the
ratings he just has to find himself that
tournament to play exactly oh my yeah
and when it comes to ratings is also
quite interesting because Ali Resa fuja
has committed himself to the Champ's
chest T which is not a part not the
rating and classical it's not part of
the he won't
even yeah and for for him it basically
Cleaves December in in half right so
he he'll be going to Toronto He he'll be
going to Toronto to play that and that's
in the middle of December which
basically rules out the entire month in
terms of tournament tournament shopping
also ala is a very very strong player in
shorter time control so you would assume
he is at least somewhat interested in
playing the world rapid and Blitz which
is at the end of the month right uh so
yeah for resa is just a it feels
heartbreaking honestly he felt like an
absolute log for the ratings spot right
and now he is very much not right and he
can't even do very much about it the way
it's structured because I don't think he
will be able to find himself a place to
play with his already announced
commitments so Joy explain once again to
our audience who may have been joining
us late the tragedy that has been Fallen
Ali Raza because at the start of
November he he was a lock for the
candidat like he was it was a certain
right you know he was just fighting with
uh hikarin Nakamura for that rating spot
Ali Resa fua started November with
2777 and wow simply wow it is absolutely
that's a fantastic rating but he's had a
terrible month and his rating has just
Fallen to what we saw earlier
2750 so essentially he's dropped 27
rating points and that could cost him
dearly a spot in the candidates ouch
ouch ouch I didn't see that coming I
don't think anybody saw that coming one
thing we we kept on returning to and
expressing our slight puzzlement over I
think uh that has been explained and
maybe we should have realized it earlier
uh the point that for the rating spot
they're only using one list and both you
and I Yer were saying we don't really
understand why that is because it always
used always used to be an average over a
certain period of time but there
actually is a very legitimate rational
explanation for this because let's say
somebody starts the year 23 at I don't
know 26 2765 wonderful and there's a
rating spot in play and this is a very
high rating I think you're in a way
incentivized to sit on it because if if
you have a lot of lists on 2765 you
average at the end of the year will be
around 2765 even if let's say there are
some fluctuations somewhere so you're
saying it's discouraging for somebody
who has a high rating at the start of
the year you you're actively discouraged
from playing chess and this is not
something fed wants I think it's
actually very good that they they're
trying to make top players play chess we
want to watch them compete exactly uh so
this is I
think an unusual change but I think it's
maybe just simply a good change but the
counterargument to that is simply the
activity requirement as we're witnessing
with lenir he just needs to improve his
activity he had been actually waiting
for uh invitations that didn't come he
was in that no man's land yeah there
there's always going to be you know pros
and cons for for any of these changes
but I think this this one I buy into the
explanation because we have seen people
just completely kind of retire from play
in the calendar year where it was
important to preserve a high average
objection object it's my It's my
prerogative it's my
responsibility
objection but yes I understand I mean
there there's pros and cons to all of it
and this has been uh uh an ongoing
discussion that we've been having
along with who's going to win the SFI
cup which is still an ongoing discussion
as two players are ti prefers going into
the final round we're going to take a
break but before we do that yeah yes sir
Boutique is on offer yes this is it uh
this year SF cup can keep you warm for
years to come with this amazingly
comfortable jacket and it truly is I
love this jacket it is very nice it
features an embroidery 2023 sinkfield
Cup logo on the left breath the St Louis
chess club logo on the back of the neck
and the 2023 Grand chess tour logo on
the right sleeve the jacket is in stock
for both men's and women's Styles and it
is available at couti stl.com for all
your chess shopping needs do go there I
don't know was the holiday
special yesterday
20% you didn't extraordinary opportunity
but I am being told if you they mention
your name name be your name put it on
they could possibly possibly get a 5%
discount hope you enjoy your
shopping
5% what role has sful Cup played in your
chess career yeah it's I mean s field
cup is of course Very known and very
prestigious tournament yeah it's indeed
my first time in you know classical
classical chess and when I was younger
it was definitely you know like the most
Val valuable to play the strong guys and
you know and to win some games
especially in be and Rapid well it's one
of the strongest tournaments in the
world so obviously it's always nice to
be in the tournament I played um only a
couple of times but it's place in a
tournament where I tend to play well so
I always feel happy to to be here again
in 20 2013 it was the first first uh
time for me to to come to the Midwest
before I've only been uh you know to
California and I didn't know really what
to expect I don't know somehow we
created such a relationship I think uh
with the chess club from from that first
tournament that I I felt like home here
because uh here uh really I mean the
people working at the club and Rex and
everybody involved in chess are so very
friendly
I think this is the Midwest type of
friendliness that I feel comfortable
with my performance in the in the
singfield Cup history has always been up
and down I've been playing since
2015 you know you're playing against the
very best players in the world it's a
very very tough very strong tournament
and it's it's fun to play I think I
played here
for one to for several times yeah I know
it's very challenging otherwise yeah
it's just a tournament when where you
can you can face like arguably strongest
opposition and one of the most
challenging events every year so
normally I'm happy to to come and play
here well it's been a special tournament
for me I've won it twice that was really
quite breakthrough because I think it
was the first Super tournament I won
I've been playing here since 2014 I
think I've only missed the first edition
which was only four players the way
we've been treated it's also set a
standard for elite chest tournaments in
terms of how to treat uh the players and
how to make a tournament great I have um
great memories here um you know
singfield cup is one of the fixtures in
the chess calendar I I don't think I've
won it yet but I'll I'll give it a shot
this time I'm looking forward to add St
Louis to my small list of interest when
I started Chas it started here to be the
first and the first time 20 12 or 13 so
I was following it since I started chess
everybody was playing here and we were
watching by internet and it was really
like motivational for me and I always
learned a lot from here well I think for
me it's rather unique because the first
event that I played in the United States
after a long break from because I grew
up in uh in New York I was born in
Florida and I I started my chess career
in the United States in New York and
then I moved to Europe so for many of my
formative years I was I was living and
training in Europe and playing in Europe
and then my first event back 2014 my
first big event back was the singfield
cup so I I hadn't uh come to the US for
a long time I hadn't played in the US
for many many years and then I came to
St Louis and I didn't really know much I
didn't know anything about the city I
didn't know much about the chess club it
was a chess event that was at the time
the strongest in the world with Magnus
Levon they were the first two players in
the world I didn't have so many
expectations but it ended up being my
best event my best performance I've ever
had and so yeah I have like a special
kind of memory of the sing field cup and
since then I've played every Edition so
from 2014 onward uh some events not as
well some events quite well but I always
have very good emotions being
[Music]
here hello I'm women's Grand Master V
Jan I will be creating content for Grand
store follow us on social media and
catch more behind the scenes
content the St Louis chess club is the
Premier chess facility in the United
States we bring the educational benefits
of Chess to thousands of students across
the St Louis area we also promote Chess
at the highest levels hosting all levels
of the US championships as well as
high-profile tournaments that attract
the world's best players become a member
and enjoy perks such as free classes and
lectures weekly tournaments and so much
more visit St less club.org to claim
your membership
today yeah um it's amazing what the club
has done for chess in general because I
mean it's already been 15 years and
they've done countless uh national
championships tournaments for juniors
helping Ground Schools and they've just
grown the game so much across the United
States I think if I look at my own
career and I look at American chest in
general we're in a much better place
than we were 15 years ago and so the
contributions have been immense and of
course it's all thanks to Dr Jun
singfield and Rex
singfield I would say that St Lua Club
is like a rock in the ocean of Chess and
we know that it's it's there it is there
it will be there I think it sense a hope
that the game of chess will always stay
Al flat by the mere factors of its
existence I think it it it sends
positive waves across the
globe
the World Chess Hall of Fame located in
the heart of St Louis's historic Central
West End want to know why chess has
intrigued people around the world for
nearly 1,500 years stop by and learn
about the impact of Chess from our three
floors showcasing the art culture and
history of the game the World Chess Hall
of Fame has something for everyone to
enjoy for more information on current
exhibits please visit World Chess h
f.org
St Louis the chess capital of the United
States it also plays host to an
award-winning shop dedicated to chess
merchandise All Occasion gifts and
plenty more at Q Boutique you can shop
both in store and online from quirky
greeting cards to luxury chest sets
there is something for everyone at Q
Boutique enjoy a shopping experience
like no other make sure to check out qou
stl.com for for a wide variety of gifts
for everyone to enjoy the St Louis chess
club Scholastic program brings the
educational value of Chess to kids and
schools across the St Louis area active
in over 100 schools throughout the St
Louis city and county the St Louis chess
club has been able to reach over 85,000
students in both in school and after
school programs we view chess as a
valuable educational tool learn more
about our Scholastic programming by
visiting St l chess club.org
education hello I'm women's Grand Master
R TOA I will take you behind the scenes
of the grand chest store follow us on
social media and don't miss out on
players interviews and more content from
the playing
Hall the St Louis chess club is the
Premier chess facility in the United
States and is among the best in the
world thanks to co-founders Dr jeie
Karen sinkfield and Rex sinkfield
the St Louis chess club is a nonprofit
organization committed to promoting the
game of chess locally and
internationally we bring the educational
benefits of Chess to thousands of
students across the St Louis area
promoting cognitive development critical
thinking concentration and analytical
skills the St Louis chess club welcomes
chess lovers of any age and skill level
to come and enjoy the game of chess we
also promote Chess at the highest levels
hosting all levels of the US
championships and the American Cup as
well as high-profile tournaments that
attract the world's best players
including the prestigious sinkfield cup
Karen's cup and many more all
tournaments can be streamed via our
YouTube and twitch channels that also
include over 2,000 chess lectures for
anyone to enjoy become a member and
enjoy perks such as free classes and
lectures weekly tournaments merchandise
discounts and so much more more visit St
Louis chess club.org to claim your
membership
[Music]
today the World Chess Hall of Fame
located in the heart of St Louis's
historic Central West End want to know
why chess has intrigued people around
the world for nearly 1,500 years stop by
and learn about the impact of Chess from
our three floors showcasing the art
culture and history of the game land
marked by the world's largest chess
piece sitting outside our front door the
World Chess Hall of Fame has something
for everyone to enjoy including various
exhibitions monthly concerts and much
more whether you are a beginner or a
professional there is something for
everyone to learn here at the World
Chess Hall of Fame enjoy free admission
to our rotating exhibitions in our
Galleries and sign up for chess events
familyfriendly programming and art
classes and don't forget to stop by our
award-winning gift shop Q Boutique and
Shop a wide selection of of Chess
related merchandise for more information
on current exhibits please visit World
Chess h.org
[Music]
St Louis the chess capital of the United
States boasts the world class St Louis
chess club and the World Chess Hall of
Fame it also plays host to an
award-winning shop dedicated to chess
merchandise All Occasion gifts and
plenty more at Q Boutique you can shop
both in store and online for chess
merchandise autograph Collectibles chess
campus souvenirs and much much more from
quirky greeting cards to luxury chess
sets there is something for everyone at
Q Boutique and all purchases go right to
benefiting new exhibitions and programs
at the World Chess Hall of Fame
dedicated to exploring chess and its
immense impact on art and culture
located on the first floor of the World
Chess Hall of Fame enjoy a shopping
experience like no other and become
everyone's favorite Gift Giver if if you
can shop in store make sure to check out
Q Boutique stl.com for a wide variety of
gifts for everyone to
[Music]
enjoy hello and welcome back to round
eight the penon round of the sink field
cup and it's been a short one so far we
we've had three games finished already
it's been a draw Fest if I say so myself
and here you can see it was a quick draw
between Anish giri against Fabiana
Carana Lena Dominguez and Maxim vasra
had a very sharp opening but it did
fizzle out into a three move repetition
for Wesley so and Yan pomi they were on
the speedway to an opposite color Bishop
end game and that ended in a draw and
Ali Resa fuja did have a buy round
because of the withdrawal of yan Krist
Duda in round two that means one game is
outstanding between Richard report and
leevon aronian but for some players
winner in the GCT tour it was good news
and smiles all around because there we
can see at the top of the table Fabiana
Carana he started this event with an 11o
Head Start Over Maxim Vash lra right and
a disaster would have meant that black
Maxim would catch up with him but as we
saw Fabiano with cl he was never going
to get a disaster and he has now secured
the title of 2023 ground chest tour
Champion with two rounds to spare and
Nets himself
$100,000 bonus our congratulations to
Fabby which is just another exclam
exclamation point to an outstanding year
and there's still the sville cup to be
determined I mean uh I don't think we've
had a GCT tour where that the GCT core
winner has won both classical events
meaning Bucharest and svi cup that Still
Remains to be determined but one game
remains in this round one game
outstanding and what an outstanding game
it is yeah uh oh
just just commentator just a
second like like a scarecrow yeah it is
outstanding in its field um KN C5 the
last move made after uh the move 7 A5 by
L1 we kept on saying that you know if if
white were to make any progress here I
think the scenario we were discussing on
break was what if black just says I want
to do nothing and I also want to give up
my Bishop pair for no particular reason
just to illustrate how solid my position
is right I think many of White's
eventual plans of playing for victory
would include gaining more space on the
queen side so Leon putting paid to that
immediately by playing A5 is very
logical and the response by by Richard
opens us up to potential sharpening of
the position because the move I'm
looking at here very much is the move
Rook D4 hasn't been played though which
ising Rook F4 is a possibility the idea
is very much to put it on F4 and also in
some lines surprisingly on H4 mhm uh I
was looking at something like uh C3 Rook
F4 Rook H2 and in these types of
positions black very much at some point
starts playing Bishop F6 and then Rook
H4 saying would you like to give me a
passer on the H file would you like to
lose the H5 Pawn which one which one do
you prefer but uh White has decent
response to the bishop Bishop B6 forcing
black to uh draw his his own Bishop all
the way back to H7 is a very decent
reply with F2 F3 just to explain why not
Knight tak7 this is actually quite
attractive for black yeah because the uh
once the bishop on G7 becomes becomes
much more alive I think these types of
positions do become interesting for
black it's probably still still drawable
for white yeah but this is definitely an
improvement it's much more fun to play
this than the previous ones but Leon
went B6 and now after Knight E6 it feels
like we are probably headed towards a
peaceful outcome you cannot not take on
E6 because Knight takes G7 and take C5
is threatened and this is also not great
no uh so Bishop takes Bishop takes will
be played I would assume Black Goes Rook
G4 Rook E4 Rook f8 black is now
completely safe the other Rook will come
in why the why the F4 Square something
like this is logical but white is also
not going to lose this position it's
just way too solid for for anyone to
play for for for a win reasonably
so uh it's a more conservative choice
we're not going to get very much
excitement out of this but we might get
a reasonably uh uh expedited conclusion
to the game because it does feel like
all four Rooks somewhere here you
probably find a way to get alls off the
board and to make a draw offer uh shall
we take a peek ahead let's do that let's
have a look round Tom exactly for the
last final round and there we see Yan
Pachi will have the white pieces against
Niche giri and look at this look at the
stats nothing can separate these two
players three victories a piece
impressive and neppo of course will be
going in tomorrow having drawn all of
his games but Anish is sitting on uh
below the watermark of 50% to quote
Peter another matchup for tomorrow will
be Maxim Vash against Ali Resa fuja and
did you expect this not that many games
and uh we see Maxim has the advantage of
one win in the rapid chess and Blitz the
St Louis it was mvl who was actually up
ending fuia in some of those very
important critical must-win games MV
took took them in the Blitz and this is
a very important game for the standings
abolutely they see Levon aronian with
the white
pieces co-leader Lena Dominguez and well
leavon aronian nursing a small Advantage
there as he has five wins to leners
three
15 draws that's a lot of draws where did
leavon beat uh lineer five times Peter
five times World Cups maybe I'm not
inside World Cups okay and then finally
the other co-leader the man of the
moment the other co-leader Fabiano Caron
a grand chest tour Champion well in the
stats he leads three wins to one against
Richard reports Richie having a poor
event standing at minus two I think
that's he's by himself Richie isn't he
at the Min
Al he's got good
company if you're going to go down with
the ship you might as well have good
company and uh this game uh Peter no I
found a way for black to go wrong though
which which surprised me Rook f8 has
been played onto the board by L Rook H
F1 looks logical Rook F4 is probably the
intention white goes Rook e four very
logical and in this position I was
slightly shocked by the fact that the
engine snaps on e4 I thought why can't
we just do this and shockingly after
white seemingly improves the black
structure with Rook takes C4 neither
yeah these positions actually start
getting a bit awkward because the bishop
will drop back to G4 and despite black
having a majority on the king side it's
really completely immobile it also
covers the E4 E2 Square I mean just for
I don't know let's put this yeah uh so
King G7 and then we start
kind of slowly slowly yeah we want to
play G3 G4 we want to bring once we've
played G3 G4 we want to put the King on
C4 we want to start hinting at some
point at the move B2 B4 whereas in
response black is just going to pass for
the next however many his majority does
nothing I assum I assume this is still a
draw but this is a kind of a draw you
can actually lose right whereas if you
just take on e4 here go Rook d8 check
and then go bishop f8 and and start and
start bringing the king in here I'm
pretty sure Rook G1 follows post haste
and we do shake
hands makes sense small trap there yeah
a little Nuance a little bit but kind of
all depended on the activity of the
black Bishop right I mean and the white
king being able to snake its way into
the queen side and that again is uh
based on this idea that we're going to
play Rook F1 we're going to go Rook F4
and uh after Rook E4 to snap it right
away just another thought that did come
to mind is this idea once again of Rook
H for Peter uh is that completely bogus
uh inviting white to actually make a
passor your it can get locked out
though honestly this is how about locked
in AR I aren't I locked in on the
k
that was
semantics semantics
Ed out it's a kind of a strange
situation where it's very possible it
never leaves this square of buty but but
it also cannot be
captured so I'm not entirely sure if
this is bad or not probably kind of
ambivalent now uh our producer looking
at his San zugs and zwang wants to make
sure that locked out is a chest term you
know you got it's it's a term chess
players use I think very often when the
because I would assume because I've done
this many a time people forget keys and
and then they are locked out locked out
exactly chess players are famously very
very I've been locked in and locked out
I've been locked in I had a bishop that
just never oh let's not go there locked
in Bishop but okay Rook uh we are at
that point where well we got one game
remaining and it's a it's a dry field uh
Peter no know the way of putting it
Bishops of opposite color we saw this in
round one four out of our five games in
that round where Bishops of opposite
color that was a theme we went into five
draws and then Duda withdrew um having
some bad luck here in St Louis also at
the um Karen's Cub we had uh Hy uh also
uh withdrawing and that really does uh
throw us off our uh Rhythm as we know D
to has actually had a very good year and
I don't know we haven't been speaking
about him in terms of candidates and
what he could mean if he could play in a
candidates tournament uh in his career
Peter he played one right he played
Madrid I don't think he played anything
PRI prior to that but Madrid was the the
conclusion of a wonderful year in which
he also won the the World Cup in Sochi
right beating beating Magnus Carlson
along the way so he's a very very
exciting player it's a extremely
regretful that yes I say he did not
finish this tournament I was very much
looking forward to uh watching him
compete he's definitely one of the more
attacking I like the words wash buling
yeah uh players on the circuit and uh U
the tournament is much the Lesser for
for his withdrawal but for sure he had
uh regrettable reasons but very valid
reasons for uh for which destroying and
wish him the the speediest recovery
absolutely we wish him the best of
health and I agree with you guys both I
mean his handle is Polish fighter and he
comes to every single game you know
wanting to win so his draw does have an
impact impactful indeed uh leavon and
Richie uh both struggling again um as
Wesley you heard in Wesley's interview
there with Anastasia Wesley say he was
gifted a point or half a point if you
prefer by uh leavon but
leavon he didn't get into his rhythm
here he was missing it it's not exactly
like that because he won that very very
exciting game against ala which was
definely one of the one of the games of
the tournament uh but yeah he's still
not anywhere near his absolute culating
best and it's it's also something that I
think many many people are
regretting Leon Leon playing well and
this is like a universal statement Leon
playing well is a is something we all
want because watching him uh in that in
that Prime form is just just so
enjoyable I think the quote was a tweet
from Gary himself who said the the
world's a better place when leavon is
playing uh his brand of Chess and same
can be said about Richie as well uh for
Richard
um creativity something also something
missing it's been a quiet year uh in
terms of results uh he moved federations
recently and that obviously impacts your
play in all kinds of in all kinds of uh
subtle ways um but yeah once again
somebody who uh round about maybe 2020
2021 perhaps 2022 even it seemed like he
was becoming better and better with
every year and uh with every game even
you know becoming a more more
well-rounded player because we always
knew what what kind of a gift he had for
messy positions for you know for being
one of the more creative players around
but he also at some point started
developing a much more solid opening
repertoire which made made him much more
solid much more competitive player in
closed Fields M uh and he qualified for
for the candidates and it seemed like
things were going reasonably well but
yeah this year hasn't been great right
yeah he has moments of Brilliance he
really does you know I remember watching
him play at a blitz tournament and he
came to the game with a well worked out
opening you know and he just completely
outclassed some of the best European
players see them both and I just love
what he brings to the table I love this
unorthodox style that he has yeah and
also he's a really good technical player
as well I I've had the pleasure of
playing Richard once in my my life and I
I just felt that the whole board was
full of tactics and you know once I I
blundered a porn by accident but somehow
I got back into it and then suddenly the
position got crazy again and I was like
wellow then I didn't couldn't handle
that one the chaos exed yeah he was just
brilliant right uh there was a there was
a player when I think of Richie uh and I
mean this as a compliment to both of
them Alexander morvich yeah uh somehow
the two of them it's a natural
comparison yeah the uh the very
unorthodox approach to the game the kind
of their own unique understanding of
what works and what doesn't and very
very exciting games yeah uh I've spent
much of my early and sort of middle
stages of my career playing playing
against Alexander marvich constantly and
it was always exhilarating but for me
also extremely difficult and not
particularly successful I don't have a
very good score against him uh it went
in waves but I think his waves were
longer and higher and whatever else you
can say about waves uh it's regrettable
that we no longer see him play I'm
pretty sure even now he would be a very
very interesting person to to to watch
play right and yeah I mean only only so
many ways we can continue saying that we
we wish Richard to return to his
absolute best because at his best he is
uh a welcome guest in every single event
but is this kind of common amongst the
elite that you go and Peaks and your
form goes in Peaks and troughs you much
so yeah uh for me uh chess had always
been a kind of a confidence game and
sometimes it's just one of those things
where maybe you're working with a
trainer where you've been very creative
uh you've put together a lot of ideas
and you come to the game gleefully and
happily like i' i' I've got these great
openings work out and then you just go
and things just click and then you have
those moments where it's just a lull
it's like you're tired like that that's
one of the things that I think uh
today's modern players are remarkably
good at they play a lot of Chess yeah
and they play at a very very high level
but at certain moment you can also wear
yourself out that's absolutely true and
no matter what you're trying you can't
win a game because you're don't just you
don't have the energy people but
sometimes you know you know chess is a
SLO you know every every single game you
know your opponent plays well and you
know you don't win necessarily in the
cleanest way you know it's a real effort
even against lower rated players and
sometimes it almost feels like for Fabby
it's been effortless these last two
victories well not the one against ala
fuja but
against it felt like a gift yeah 10
moves uh or well maybe it was move 11
I'm not exactly sure but Queen very
unusual game between two players of that
caliber exactly Wy said he had an off
day and you can that can happen of
course yeah you you could see it
unfolding before our eyes and and this
also sort of returns us to this
conversation we had a bit uh earlier in
today's broadcast uh about what's
happening in this tournament and how to
improve it and also the comparison that
everybody makes because it's the correct
comparison between uh let's say the
grest or classical events and
specifically the Tata Steel in vikon yes
which is a first of all it's a 14 player
field so you you have yeah you have much
what I meant is yeah it's a longer
tournament it's a much more grueling
tournament in terms of just stamina and
all that but my point was more that the
the extended field allows the organizers
and they also specifically strive for
that every year to invite a mix of the
absolute top players and the exciting
youngsters that everybody wants to see
and that creates that feel that you were
describing I don't know if I mean these
days the youngsters are still good that
your description of this is a point and
this is a point I don't know if that is
true to be honest but but you do get uh
a mix of players which means that uh
it's not the same pairings over and over
and over again which is I think the
common complaint and I think a valid
complaint that people have about some of
the the absolute top events I don't
think uh you the idea of the grand chest
stour is inviting the absolute top of
the profession yeah the Merit this
cannot really be criticized it's a very
valid way of you know settling scores by
inviting only the very very best but you
do end up with this slightly closed
field where you get the same people
playing over and over uh against each
other at some point they kind of exhaust
ideas against each other and you do on
occasion uh get uh events where nobody's
perhaps playing particularly well
nobody's playing particularly poorly and
you get these kind of correct played
rounds where nothing much is happening
the way to fight it and I've never been
a kind of a classical chess alarmist I
don't think we need to like revor it
from from the ground up slight even ever
so slightly more mixed Fields already
pretty much completely solve that
problem we see VI W has like an average
rating of 2700 it's not a weak
tournament at all but it has very good
decisive percentages it's very exciting
to watch and nobody I think when you're
watching V you don't really get very
many complaints about how how classical
chess is boring right also in my day I
just uh saying that Kasparov and karpov
those two players in particular were the
highest rated players of the day and uh
they played against each other an
amazing number of games I want to say
like
120 maybe more um just classical games
and nobody ever complained about
whenever they were matched up it didn't
matter whether it being a Laris or a uh
Las palus or any of their matches
everybody was very happy to see number
one and number two Clash uh again
Bishops of opposite color it still
feels well pretty dry well it does feel
pretty dry but um I do see that C3 was
played and I was expecting Rook takes
Rook yeah I'm a bit surprised by Rook d
coming bringing us back to the board for
a second there we left it after Rook
Leon chose Rook f8 Rook H F1 he didn't
play Rook F4 here which already was a
bit surprising he has gone with Rook d8
Rook uh D4 white white went C3 and even
here I wonder if he actually dislikes
this end
game uh
because uh if anyone can play here it's
white but it feels very very unlikely
the way because like the only break
available in the position is B24 it's
not going to be easy to prepare and
black can also pretty much ignore it
like you play Rook B1 and can play King
G7 before first of all I can probably
take and go with a draw but also I'm
pretty sure I can just not do anything
no actually it doesn't say I can yeah
passing here would be would be very
dangerous so maybe he actually did not
want to get involved with uh calculating
all of this because why does have A4 A5
in these types of positions and you do
have to be certain that the a pawn
doesn't doesn't survive which it doesn't
because we can attack it from behind and
pick it
up but the move Rook D6 because I really
don't think it's a move to play for a
win I think it somewhat indicates that
Leon was a bit worried about Rook E4 D4
that he didn't quite
like the way this was leading to a draw
I'm pretty sure he knows it was leading
to a draw generally but he didn't he he
preferred this and now rook
fd8 and here uh honestly yeah uh Richard
instantly plays Bishop B2 which is the
correct way to to go uh you don't want
to give up the on D3 and Rook E3 would
allow E5 E4 oh yeah and and and letting
black play this would make Black's life
a lot easier because the bishop on G7
you're still maybe a little bit worse
because B3 is a very safe Square for
this King but black can give a check
maybe play B6 B5 if you do put it on B3
and it's it's okay after Bishop B2
breaks are not going to be available and
white you know slowly slowly could
perhaps hope to put the King on C2 I
think white probably wants to trade one
pair of Rooks somehow to not have to
care about the D3 Pawn because it will
be amply protected by the king so let me
let me paint an ideal scenario here for
white right we do something like yeah
just
to I don't know I'm I'm going to make a
really bad move here and some more
really really bad moves you can do it
something something like this this is
make like normal play he's a terrible
atrocious I I definitely can trust me
I'm I'm aware uh and in a position like
this with the bishop already on e4 okay
and now we can maybe dream of playing
Rook G1 Rook B1 pushing B4 and starting
to ask some questions whereas for black
there will not be any counterplay
available at all but along the way uh of
course you know even allowing The Rook
to lift from from G1 without having
played F2 F3 is unnecessary I can put my
Rook on the f file and ask you exactly
how you're achieving any of that uh Leon
in the meantime uh played C6 C5 which is
also a way to deal with potential b2ak
sure about this actually because it does
allow the king to potentially go to
slightly different position though yeah
it's with the King on D2 but it doesn't
matter like next next three moves by
Richard I'm pretty I'm pretty sure I
know what they are King comes over here
and then we're trying to find the good
Square for this bishop it's probably the
square on e4 so we're trying to play
something like Rook E3 followed by
Bishop F
34 honestly I I am very unimpressed with
how Leon is approaching this he's
basically saying this is solid enough
that I can give you all the freedom in
the world and this will still not
collapse but the start the starting
point of it allowing white absolutely
everything I don't quite like I've lost
games like this I've done this myself
and it cost me and I I don't really like
this as a as a as a con concept of
approaching these types of end games
Bishop of Pap a color if I might uh the
very
position that they have on the board at
this moment because there was one uh I
think practical question I would have
like to ask instead of the move Bishop
E2 Rook E3 once again and you had
mentioned E4 and I would like to ask you
about D4 C5 it gets immediately
undermine of course I take you take and
I go C4 you I have it on the screen I
checked this you have to play D3
exactly it's pretty good it's pretty
good because now the bishop is alive
exactly and you can play B3 but after B3
already say bishop f8 and tries to put
on B4 who's better now who's playing
it's it's black although it's still
manageable yeah exactly okay so that was
a an important little detail and we have
King G8 on the board again unless leavon
seriously mishandles this and sadly for
his fans they did witness that in his
game with Wesley so uh he seriously
mishandled the night versus and by the
way this reminds us of that game against
Wesley doesn't it in in in in a in a
weird fashion because against Wesley as
well he very early on in that
resulting endgame Bishop against
Knight he he very very early on just
said okay I'll give you the maximum and
I will hold it right and it turned out
that no no that's the maximum was really
too much yes you you actually gave the
maximum but then you you can't hold it
anymore exactly and he is sort of doing
the same thing today in a much more
solid like the starting point is much
much more solid than what he had against
Wesley this doesn't look lost but still
it's still a very similar approach and
I'm not really in favor of it uhhuh of
what he's done do you think he's uh
planning to I think run with the King to
the Seas sorry yeah not not the defense
but I think he wants to go uh his King
more or less uh to March his King
players are moving super quickly here to
the queen side in other words he's
anticipating that Richie's Richard's
King will get to the B5 square and then
he thinks that it's to say leavon would
like to have his King on C7
just basically guarding the B6 Pawn I
think his last move just now very much
illustrates that point if we it looks
like this famous quote unquote
mysterious Rook move Rook d8 f8 it has a
point you you put it in front of your
own king and the point is if you play
King E7 immediately you're very much
allowing F4 gf4 Rook takes F4 and this
is a massive Improvement because starts
get scary yeah we got rid of our one
backward Pawn we've opened up the G file
to start harassing your your your pieces
on the king side the engine really
bottoms out here it says this is
basically winning for white so wow so
after Rook f8 we want to play King E7
next move and let me let me make a move
here yeah and if you do F4 here
obviously black has one more piece
attacking this Square so we just win a
PA on the4 and don't allow white I'm
just laughing cuz it looks like the
evaluation bar is like staunchly in the
middle despite blundering upon I BL I
blundered a full Pawn here and it still
says absolutely zero not nothing doing
right nothing doing which I think is a
kind of a useful indication of just how
comfortable white is here right now I
forget the players names but it was
actually pretty hilarious a a very very
locked Pond structure with Bishops being
locked behind the pawn
structure and one player says to the
other move with this uh move I offer a
draw and the player said well let me
think about it let me think about it the
player said okay look I'm going to
remove my
bishop and it will still be a draw
okay so I'm going to remove my bond will
still be a draw just like just a blunder
at a pond and the evaluation bar didn't
move um would that move Rook f8 did that
secure by the engine standards equality
I it gives white a solid 040 advantage
and shuffles forever I would assume you
can't actually make progress because
your your two breaks are here at D4 and
F4 and B4 I guess and black is very
prepared to just continue trading
continue trading in those cases yes yeah
what it does does open us up to is that
interminable shuffling that might that
might follow from here because white is
perfectly justified in looking for
something to do if I may so you played
Rook f8 I'll go King B5 what else okay
I'll go Rook C4 what else okay um now at
a certain moment what I want is F3 Rook
C1 and B4 I can I can even play King C7
because I think if you play if you break
with B before at the wrong moment yeah
the point is I was I thought it was Rook
A8 somewhere but it actually goes Rook
B8 with the King on B5 and says now can
you please take something so that I can
give you mate yeah please check mate
yourself beautiful you've kind of
self-mated the white
king in particular here I very much like
the fact that we can continue making
Quiet Moves here with
a what are those problems called when
you when self I think it's help it's
helpmate yeah I just I just performed a
helpmate on
myself nicely done well that was the
break as you were mentioning before and
uh if I'm going to walk myself into a
helpmate well no breaks not not very
promising no not very promising and also
once the king is on C7 perhaps the one
actually does play Rook F4 yeah and says
yeah you can take maybe it improves his
structure a little bit but with the pawn
already on C5 he will never play D3 G
for and it's manageable although I
wouldn't recommend it I don't think it's
a great idea but you know there's one
rule in this competition no draw offers
allowed that's right how are these
players going to even come close to kind
of indicating to the other that they I
think it would be a three move
repetition King B5 and then King C4 and
then yeah that kind of a a unspoken draw
yeah but then you're stepping backwards
and say for instance you know and black
go well you know you go backwards I go
forward I'm going to step up to King C
isn't really going to go forward in this
game there's like no forward to go
to trying to get her it's like you just
reminded me of you know the story that
you told earlier on where Anish giri was
playing against Maxim Vash lra and he
thought it was just a casual draw yeah
was and then suddenly he Dawns on him
that MV playing for win right oops oops
uh leavon doesn't look like uh he's like
looking around what's for he's he's he's
a bit pensive I feel wasn't it vishy who
had that interview postgame interview
where Mr Anan Mr Anan what were you
actually thinking of at this precise
moment he was thinking of what to have
for
dinner like oh you know I'm a big Foody
that has never ever crossed my mind not
for me either during a game not at all
at all nice shirt ABS nice very
attractive uh I got busted by Larry
Christensen I was playing in a US
championship and having a winning
position against uh uh shabalov which I
lost and somebody in the audience asked
me so yes sir what did you think about
this did you think about that and Larry
Christensen said said no he was thinking
about his victory speech and if I won
that game I would win the championship
on the spot and he was absolutely
right yeah was about
my I went red it was like ah busted yeah
I think I think something like that was
also also said about me by Alexander
grishuk once I think what did you do
that no he just like correctly at some
point just correctly said that Peter is
probably thinking about the interviews
he's going to be giving up and it wasn't
even a particularly exciting game but it
does occasionally something amusing will
come to my mind and I will start
thinking about like how exactly how to
phrase it if because sometimes in in
years going by I would play in
tournaments where you would get
interviewed regardless of how exciting
your game was so I knew there would be
an interview right there wasn't a so you
were prepped it wasn't a particular
presumptuous you know idea on my part
and I would have this this like one line
prepared and I would sort of fine-tune
it during the round instead of actually
paying attention to the board oops it's
all not very productive and not to be
recommended no have you well no I've
never thought about a victory
spe not a good idea I have thought about
um comedy sketches and during the game
and also music you know some annoying
jingle and air worm comes in and it just
keeps going on a loop it's fine when
it's a particular energetic song but
sometimes I've had like I'm a loser
going that's the worst kind of song you
want in imagine that must have been
come on that's one of the like creep
creep is one of the modern Classics
having having creep as your as your
soundtrack to the game is not not a bad
idea no it's a terrible idea I mean you
need you know you need to have like
positive stuff you need to kind of
subconsciously yeah yeah yeah uplifting
Prime yeah you got to Prime the Mind
although the funny thing is that if you
try to deliberately do it it doesn't
work right but if someone does it
subconsciously like puts up a poster
saying copy DM you know something cheesy
like that then for some reason it works
we are now going to talk about
replication
crisis you're aware you're aware this
all been disproven right the priming
theory is bunk but I'm reading this book
called psyched up and it's saying it's
true no it's about the no I am I am
going to my my hobby horse here and talk
about replication crisis my neck back
down uh in the meanwhile just a second
guys just a second uh somebody's gone
down on time uh Richie uh has
actually 8
minutes why is he going into a such a
deep think uh Peter is he has the the to
do that move 35 Rook e it's not serious
Time Crisis at the minute yeah okay so
is this a potential
yeah I'm wondering G no nobody goes King
G8 I nobody goes King G8 of course not I
mean and also like I think everybody
still goes King E7 but the point is if
you put the Rook back on e4 nobody goes
King F7 sadly for you nobody goes King
F7 they go King D7 even though you have
now offered a draw I'm still pretty sure
leevon will not bring himself to to play
King F7 this position the move is just
too pointless to make exactly but you
did mention that perhaps White's Bishop
would like to be on the E4 square but
you this is this involves perhaps giving
up some material oh hang on I blended
the E5 Square oh the E5 yeah then maybe
does make yeah that maybe does make
sense like like say King G8 Bishop
before it does let us entertain some
thoughts but yeah put my Bishop on G6
it's possible that he's aiming towards
something like this here exactly uh
we've been also talking about the Gayla
the upcoming fer sir uh of December and
here it is strategy across the board
there is a fantastic silent auction and
there we have itth coming up Saturday
December 2nd if you're anywhere near the
Central West End here in uh St Louis
you're really going to want to attend
this uh we had Brian uh Woods uh
explaining what kind of music
performances he's going to have we've
got Sharon Carpenter in town to help MC
uh the event as and special guest Marina
toybina who is uh a designer she's been
using the theme of chass in a lot of her
shows exactly and that will be a very
very nice along with the silent auction
uh to uh shop the items and make your
bids if you like what's happening in St
Louis you can support yeah you can our
have a look at what's up for auction on
that website 23
sb. givesmart.com
so check it out and have a look and get
bidding get bidding uh givesmart
givesmart God that threw me off
givesmart yes I'm trying to associate
that with a word can't Rook maybe G
smart giv smart like I'm very bad at
like get smart we used to have this
wonderful TV show get smart agents of
control and Chaos never we Rook F3 yeah
I think I think this is maybe winding
down now because I mean a very logical
reply here would be Rook df6 because you
know trading on F3 and giving white an
additional couple tempies to to to bring
the king the one actually shoes all of
this just goes King d8 which is also
fine I guess although I'm a bit
surprised Rook df6 seemed just like such
a logical move you take with the Rook
you bring the king over to C7 you go
Bishop f8 Bishop D6 and that really is
on Lock by that point because we've also
completely ruled out2 before with afraid
of a potential King D5
King D5 I'm not 100% sure let me just
put that so we did see the move Rook F3
King to d8 and as you were saying Peter
there was a you know this looks very
very
logical actually having having seen what
he's done it will probably lead to
exactly the same position maybe one
tempo short is there any reason that the
king might I don't know come in take the
pawn on E5 no no help me yeah but Los a
piece no I don't know King D5 Rook D6
check though and aftering E4 I put it
back on F6 and I want to play King D6
Rook F4 check good point that would be
uh good enough I'm going to just refresh
my board for just a moment to get the
current position as we did see this Rook
trade on f8 Bishop takes
f8 well again nothing something like
Bishop G4 I suppose King C7
F3 and Bishop G4 King C7
F3 and then we want to play I guess we
wait
yeah G7 and we try to I don't know I'm
not sure what the winning plan here is
why can we not mobilize The Rook
absolutely where would you like to put
it I put it on F
six it's going to F4 y oh you want to
play for
black we were trying to we were trying
to find a winning plan of any kind for
white I I agree you might you you're
you're more than oops I I'll make a move
and I you're more than welcome to put
your Rook on to F4 but you won't say
that this is a winning plan for for
black I was just wondering if there's a
winning plan of any type for white and
because I I've got the break I've got B4
and I've got d4s breaks assuming that E4
and C4 are not um you're not party to
making any break
yourself so I it's difficult to achieve
right what's that this B4 break I mean
you can go Rook B1 and TR that that was
why I was trying to do it with Rook C7
remember with the four Rooks how I
manage like imagining that I have this
position I'm still not threatening B4 by
the way Peter and I was going to say
with the Rook on E1 the one kind of a
cheerful thought for white is with the
black Bishop already on
D6 it would feel feel that there's just
nothing we can ever do right but it's
still on G7 where it's not doing very
much but the moment our Rook departs
from the e file black will instantly I
feel Play Bishop F Bishop D6 you think
and then and then things really are
completely loged down and I can't figure
out I I thought in the position you have
specifically on the board yes I was
trying to calculate D4 which is maybe
the only way you can ever do anything
here at all D4 using the fact that e
takes D4 Rook E7 loses a piece right
so you have to take with the c pawn and
then the Rook yep giving me a check I
with great Triumph announce that I've
given one check in this game right uh
but the thing is I just don't buy it
myself like I don't understand what I'm
achieving even if the B6 Pawn Falls it's
just not going to be enough but I I
don't understand why we're putting the
bishop on G4 like why not maximize it to
the E4 Square well I was about to say I
mean Bishop G4 on the board G
the genius that we are if you go King B7
in this position Bishop C8 check checks
you yet again oh okay you're feeling my
wrath two checks in a
row yeah it is scary very very very much
so yeah because if you put the King on
B8 you can even by the way King B King
B8 might actually be a problem we will
switch back to the actual game in a
second but King B8 King A6 King King A6
whoops yeah Rook Rook G8
kind of needs to be played now right and
we go like Rook C6 Rook C6 yeah this
might be very very with the shout yeah
absolutely see there was a reason we put
our Bishop on G4 Richie got it yeah he
got the memo uh let me just refresh my
my uh current
position by the way um because two
players are tight for first is a serious
chances of a playoff absolutely we
haven't could even have a three-way
playoff as well say for instance if Fano
and Len lose and we have we could have a
pile up actually yeah we could have a
pile because wesle sitting on plus is
50% so just briefly in tomorrow's round
yes uh for that to happen uh lenier will
need to lose to leevon Leon will go to
plus one okay and Fabby will lose to
Richard will not plus one so let's say
in in this very very imaginary scenario
we could have Leon on plus one Fabi on
plus one wesle on plus one and then
let's say Yan bit mhm Yan bitson Nish we
have a five way tyer first excellent uh
probability of that z0 approaches
approaches zero
rapidly well but how would we solve a
five way typ first look at how
everything would be be resolved so first
up if two players are ti for first it is
just simply a two game rapid match at
the time control of 15 minutes plus 10
seconds but if there are three or more
players typ for first well it will be a
blitz round robin a shorter time control
of 10 minutes plus 5 seconds per move
and if everything is still tied after
these criteria then will everything will
be decided by oh it's my favorite
armagon
5 minutes for white 4 minutes for black
but black gets draw odds and there is no
added time bonus per move so things get
so intense and you can just tell that I
just love that I know uh I mean and
those playoffs will take place tomorrow
they're not the next day or anything
like that after the round the tournament
will be finished and decided tomorrow
we're crowning a champion tomorrow
absolutely promise yes okay good good
because I saw Wesley in his interview
he's saying I'm not 100% certain I want
it to be 100 100% certain uh uh about
that uh Rook F6 played which does allow
King D5 and I've noticed that uh the
engine reacts to King D5 by playing Rook
F4 and then not protecting the pawn on
e4 anyway playing King C7 is it the oh
A4 is hanging sorry yeah A4 is hanging
but I was still kind of curious about
that what if we take if you take the
aorn is the king going to go
[Music]
Rog yeah I want to head over to to those
squares but apparently this setup with
with the Rook Bishop on f8 and The Rook
on F4 is very very sturdy and also we
now have our own our own play maybe we
start with B5 first to prevent C4
because if we if we add the white Pawn
to the a file here the very simple idea
of Rook E1 E8 takes f8 followed by King
takes H6 would probably win the game
outright but because there is going to
be a passer on the a file pretty soon
here you can't do that with but there is
the option in this particular position
of white trading Rooks like that's
something that black has to be very
careful of this is this is a passer
already yeah but I'm just thinking your
H6 porn Okay so first I'll take she
wants that yeah I I I'm not first of all
you need to control control that I will
control it yeah and and black actually
you can abandon this one to play Bishop
D4 and then it actually becomes kind of
sharp yeah yeah and uh in fact in this
position you have to start ruin it yes
sir yeah amazingly the only way to make
a draw here is to start heading back you
know running running towards the danger
zone yeah all the way all the way down
up like dropping you know dropping the
shoes and everything like you we're
sprinting towards the shito square
here yeah I really do have that imagery
too of like a shopper gone wrong you
know like really overdone it going
towards the G6 Pond uh Bishops of
opposite color there just the resources
are just there too much of dra it's now
less less completely uh dry than it than
it used to be I believe we have F3 he
played F3 you probably give that check
having played Rook F6 it would be kind
of strange not to give that check right
you can also go King C7 first I wonder
if you actually worse if you play King
C7 and then let's say Bishop D6 yeah the
engine starts saying this is maybe a
problem because now if you play Rook
F4 uh this plan is supposedly much
faster we're threatening King G7 and
let's say if Rook F4 we go King G6 and
the difference is we've taken on E5
already and we can also throw in C3 C4
which is actually something that the
machine does here and the interesting
bit here is that after something like
King D6 even this end game I'm assum
assuming at some point we're maybe going
to threaten to play Rook E4 and to
actually trade the Rooks to play King F7
G7 and pick up on H6 so you can imagine
this becoming a little bit of a you know
squeaky bum time for Leon but uh don't
know still still feels like there should
be a draw though
yeah yeah agreed agreed I would I like
the king going rogue actually uh squeaky
bum it's more for soccer holigans
it's a it's a great expression though it
is it is got to love it uh Bishop on a
G4 well we seen where where uh where
things could go wrong uh for leavon and
where things can go wrong for Richard
losing the A4 Pawn with the Rooks off
the board there can be some issues but
uh I don't know th those variations
where the king does get to G6 I would
want nothing to do with them just avoid
them like the plague but does that mean
therefore that leavon doesn't check on
F4 and instead just focuses on putting
the king say on sorry let me just uh
refresh the board to get the current
position I do like this uh Bishop to D6
but that again King C7 were very passive
there but then do
nothing okay let's I go here let's say
you go here say King C7 and Rook E1 and
now I essentially I'm moving my king
back and
forth where you where's your break in
these D D4 put your in a nice I I will
improve the r yeah and if you like you
can also put your Pawn on B3 so that I'm
kind of detached right mhm and now you
can get in D4 if you like so you've got
Rook E8 as a potential Gateway but I
don't know I'm just thinking
like don't I have just have uh a
fortress of sort my Rook on F6 and my
Bishop will be anchored on either f8 or
C5 yeah I'm not I'm not seeing it so
maybe not D4 maybe wait yeah with that
one I'm just going to be going my my my
next M I
go he's put his Bishop on D6 more or
less the setup uh challenging uh
Peter are you inspired by Rook takes E5
uh no not particularly because we're
never we're never crossing the f file if
we do that exactly that's problem is the
problem you you would need to get to the
like in the position that positions that
you were discussing which is something
along the lines of this and this you can
consider this but then you realize that
after Rook F4 you're just never getting
to the H6 Pawn in fact you probably just
lost here because this is a fixed
structure andent eventually black will
open something on the queen side right
uh no this this sacrifice doesn't really
Inspire very much and probably nothing
really inspires very much I'm
still uh I've done this myself once or
twice I remember yeah memories
unpleasant memories comeing flooding
back yeah cuz I I remember I defended
some end games in exactly this fashion
where you just say to your opponent this
is my setup this is my state do do
whatever you want I have an idea I have
an idea okay so my plan is once I've
defended F3 and solidified perhaps the
queen side I'm going to transfer the
bishop to
F5 yeah you can actually yeah you can
actually try this I was I was thinking
about that as well uh yeah like like
here because that Bishop using
Untouchable okay yes okay or G where do
you want it here um it doesn't matter
for the time being I I will be let me
let me let me continue passing show me
show me where you want you your your
your Rook will go where Joy uh my Rook
is going to go back now to B1
okay Happy Days King D7 go for it and is
B4 going to get me some well no I got
covered everything is covered I will
take and you'll give me a password now
you can play but but now I can I can
Zippity the other
way Zippity away yeah
and I feel like the bishop is better and
now we're maybe creating an idea of
before and yeah yes I play Bishop six
and I'm kind of lost but if if I exhibit
some sentence here and go and go like
King
D7 getting off the cile which was a
potential check I understand it's not a
given but any sentence at any point but
if I do exhibit some sentence here and
sidestep the one Telegraph threat that
white
we're back to this being Shuffle Shuffle
well it was you know like a niche
getting lull to sleep there we we we we
we did that Jedi mind trick on Peter and
kept his King on C7 so we could play The
Grind Masters the grind we officially
call them they do this a lot you know
they just keep shuffling shuffling
shuffling making innocuous moves and
there somewhere within that boredom
there's a dangerous move but by then you
complet your sense of danger has
completely gone out sleep
yeah yeah it's the it's the right way to
go about things Magnus has done that
hearu he loves shuffling shuffling shff
I think specifically the term comes from
the from the course Magnus has recorded
with David how yeah where go what's the
term sorry the the No No the grind
Master the grind Master Okay you say
you're not out to win
friends
tagline yeah tagline we're not it's not
about making friends y yeah how do I
lose my
Christmas uh wish lists uh but Hikaru
also he likes just shuffling shuffling
especially in the Blitz and the rapid he
enjoys that and nepo maybe to a little
degree he loves kind of just keeping the
game somehow on on the topic and I I
didn't really want to you know upset
upset Momo when he was here but I
thought about that graphic that we had
about yan yan being
the the longest winning player in in the
history of singfield cups with 65 move
average and then I thought of the other
graphic we have for this tournament and
I thought maybe he just won like three
and one of them is3 F moves long against
Wesley and that's
because that just skews everything in
the direction of of yan and it could be
it's just this one outlier which throws
us off and he is just an the exciting
player that we know in love but it's a
it's a kind of sometimes I'm a little
bit worried about that that the data set
is a little bit too small and uh you
know uh when we refer to like how many
times has one E4 been played in the sing
cup how many times has ju D4 been played
in we need to have you know like a
hundredy year history and just for fun
let's have a look at the winners and
losers graphic that Peter was
referencing and there you can see fua
has the lowest average move count when
he wins 33 and Richard report also there
with 38 Buton Bashi 65 the way the way
to either improve or completely ruin
this graphic would be to actually
include in bracket somewhere the number
of games that this is this average is
being derived from that Neo might might
have come from that how many how many
winning games are we talking here right
exactly uh but but a big number of uh
wins there how about on the other side
the flip side of the coin and the
average move count of losing games well
there we have at the top Dominguez cuz
he doesn't lose games at the
S cup yeah he's at the bottom there but
he's
undefeated and giri is there with 59 and
then now we have this lovely stat lethal
winners and stubborn losers and peruja
only has three single cup wins the only
has one but Peru's wins only came from
one event last year she won she won out
right I mean stubborn stubborn winner
actually they haven't won a game in this
both fuja and Report haven't won a game
in this year's SEL cup that yeah that
hurts that that
hurts uh and uh the players have reached
the time control uh for a moment there
it looked like Richie was going down to
eight minutes but I think uh that uh
yeah they have made it to time control
which means the players do get that 30
move additional time and perhaps time
for us to take our third break but first
of all let's check out the results so
far well it was a day for the quick
draws Anish giri and Fabiana Carana
agreeing a very early draw as did weso
and Yana Pachi and Dominguez and Vash
lra so one game still remaining between
Richard reports and Leon aronian and
remember Ali Resa fua because of yan
Kristoff duda's withdrawal in round two
did not play today how a bu and uh
reserve your places at the jingle bar uh
we have we're party central in the
Central West End you can go to the
website
and uh see what we have I'm looking at
that hot chocolate there with the
cinnamon stick it looks good yes that's
all I can
say we got we got to reserve our uh
seats and we're going to go on break we
are so see you all in a few
[Music]
moments
uh so today's Community Day all the
persents of the US Championship are
going to schools around St Louis and you
know teaching kids um openings and games
uh tactics doing some fun stuff like
hand and brain some simos and uh we just
finished our first class and it was
really fun I see kids taking the um
skills that they're learning in chess
whether that be critical thinking
decision- making skills planning skills
and I see them applying that throughout
the rest of their school day whether
it's in classes or sports or even just
how they interact with one another and
with their teachers I play with my
auntie myom my sisters sometimes on the
weekends like we go to the park and we
play they be begging me to teach them I
like show them like new stuff like new
openings I show them that and so I'm
trying to see them get better and try to
beat me what I like about Chess is just
trying to have fun and learn new things
and maybe I'll get more into it and
it'll maybe be my full career I heard
that if you play chess you make bad
decisions in life so I always want to
make better decisions in life I can tell
you that they've engaged more in uh
critical thinking they are looking
analytically at moves and trying to
think ahead head I like the um
complexity of Chess how you have to
think about every single move you make
like every move you make whether it's
going to put your king in check whether
it's going to put put your anything in
danger whether it's just a move that you
make everything counts in the long run I
like um how it makes me use my critical
thinking makes me look at the whole
board I think it's teaching them to be
persistent you know we have a lot of
students who it takes them like it may
take a few weeks or even months in chess
club to master a particular strategy or
skill um and what I think that teaches
kids is even if they don't get it the
first time around or even if it's
difficult the first time around um it's
worth sticking to it well one thing's
for certain without the St Louis chess
club we would not have chess instructors
because I don't know if you all know
this but there is a critical shortage of
teachers and Educators and especially
those in areas that are not core content
area and because of the St Louis chess
club collaboration we have people who
come in here working with students who
want to work with them today with the
experience of The Grandmaster community
outreach day I came up and I'm like well
what's a grandm and they like oh you
don't know what a grand master is and
they were able to explain that and they
recognize the importance and the
seriousness I mean it's a sport it's a
profession and so they're able to see
things outside of the sports that we
typically promote in school makes me
feel good because like learning stuff
like this will help me learn help me
build my problem solving skills help me
build strategy and like you know helping
my
[Music]
brain hello I'm women's Grand Master V
Jan I will be creating content for
grandest store follow us on social media
and catch more behind the scenes
content the St Louis chess club is the
Premier chess facility in the United
States we bring the educational benefits
of Chess to thousands of students across
the St Louis area we also promote Chess
at the highest levels hosting all levels
of the US championships as well as
high-profile tournaments that attract
the world's best players become a member
and enjoy perks such as free classes and
lectures weekly tournaments and so much
more visit St Louis chess club.org to
claim your membership
today
yeah um it's amazing what the club has
done for chess in general because I mean
it's already been 15 years and they've
done countless uh national championships
tournaments for juniors helping around
schools and they've just grown the game
so much across the United States I think
if I look at my own career and I look at
American chest in general we're in a
much better place than we were 15 years
ago and so the contributions have been
immense and of course it's all thanks to
Dr Jun singfield and rexing
I would say that St lucious Club is like
a rock in the ocean of Chess and we know
that it's it's there it is there it will
be there I think it's sense a hope that
the the game of chess will always stay
Float by the M fact of its existence I
think it it it sends positive waves
across the
[Music]
globe the World Chess Hol Fame located
in the heart of St Louis's historic
Central West End want to know why chess
has intrigued people around the world
for nearly 1500 years stop by and learn
about the impact of Chess from our three
floors showcasing the art culture and
history of the game the World Chess Hall
of Fame has something for everyone to
enjoy for more information on current
exhibits please visit World Chess h.org
St Louis the the chess capital of the
United States it also plays host to an
award-winning shop dedicated to chess
merchandise All Occasion gifts and
plenty more at Q Boutique you can shop
both in store and online from quirky
greeting cards to luxury chest sets
there is something for everyone at Q
Boutique enjoy a shopping experience
like no other make sure to check out Q
Boutique stl.com for a wide variety of
gifts for everyone to enjoy the St Louis
chess club plastic program brings the
educational value of Chess to kids and
schools across the St Louis area active
in over 100 schools throughout the St
Louis city and county the St Louis chess
club has been able to reach over 85,000
students in both in school and after
school programs we view chess as a
valuable educational tool learn more
about our Scholastic programming by
visiting St Louis chess club.org
education hello I'm women's ground
master master toova I will take you
behind the scenes of the gr chest tour
follow us on social media and don't miss
out on players interviews and more
content from the playing
Hall the St Louis chess club is the
Premier chess facility in the United
States and is among the best in the
world thanks to co-founders Dr jeie
Karen singfield and Rex sinkfield the St
Louis chess club is a nonprofit
organization committed to promoting the
game of chess locally and
internationally we bring the educational
benefits of Chess to thousands of
students across the St Louis area
promoting cognitive development critical
thinking concentration and analytical
skills the St Louis chess club welcomes
chess lovers of any age and skill level
to come and enjoy the game of chess we
also promote Chess at the highest levels
hosting all levels of the US
championships and the American Cup as
well as high-profile tournaments that
attract the world's best players
including the prestigious sinkfield cup
Ken cup and many more all tournaments
can be streamed via our YouTube and
twitch channels that also include over
2,000 chess lectures for anyone to enjoy
become a member and enjoy perks such as
free classes and lectures weekly
tournaments merchandise discounts and so
much more visit St Louis chess club.org
to claim your membership today
[Music]
the World Chess Hall of Fame located in
the heart of St Louis's historic Central
West End want to know why chess has
intrigued people around the world for
nearly 1,500 years stop by and learn
about the impact of Chess from our three
floors showcasing the art culture and
history of the game landmarked by the
world's largest chess piece sitting
outside our front door the World Chess
Hall of Fame has has something for
everyone to enjoy including various
exhibitions monthly concerts and much
more whether you are a beginner or a
professional there is something for
everyone to learn here at the World
Chess Hall of Fame enjoy free admission
to our rotating exhibitions in our
Galleries and sign up for chess events
familyfriendly programming and art
classes and don't forget to stop by our
award-winning gift shop Q Boutique and
Shop a wide selection of Chess related
merchandise for more information on
current exhibits please visit world
chess h.org
St Louis the chess capital of the United
States boasts the worldclass St Louis
chess club and the World Chess Hall of
Fame it also plays host to an
awardwinning shop dedicated to chess
merchandise All Occasion gifts and
plenty more at Q Boutique you can shop
both in store and online for chess
merchandise autograph Collectibles chess
campus souvenirs and much much more from
quirky greeting cards to luxury chest
sets there is something for everyone at
Q Boutique and all purchases go right to
benefiting new exhibitions and programs
at the World Chess Hall of Fame
dedicated to exploring chess and its
immense impact on art and culture
located on the first floor of the World
Chess Hall of Fame enjoy a shopping
experience like no other and become
everyone's favorite Gift Giver if you
can shop in store make sure to check out
Q bouti stl.com for a wide variet of
gifts for everyone to
[Music]
enjoy the St Louis chess club Scholastic
program brings the educational value of
Chess to kids and schools across the St
Louis area active in over 100 schools
throughout the St Louis city and county
the St Louis chess club has been able to
reach over 85,000 students in both in
school and after school programs we
created the select chess training
program and the junior select chess
training tring program in order to
elevate the skill level in students
across the St Louis area these students
receive professional training from
grandm verua niobian other programs
include chess cops a partnership with
the St Louis Police Department looking
to improveed relationships between
atrisk kids and police officers in the
St Louis area with over 600 students
playing chess over the board since
2019 the St Louis chess club has also
created a chess merit badge for the
scouts BSA quickly becoming one of the
most popular badges with more than
250,000 Scouts earning the badge since
2011 students of chess can also pick up
a copy of read and write chess thanks to
Club co-founder Dr jeie Ken sinkfield
anyone can learn how to understand chess
notation in no time we view chess as a
valuable educational tool learn more
about our Scholastic programming by
visiting St Louis chess club.org
[Music]
education hello chess fans I'm Anastasia
Carlovich woman grandmas and I'm here in
St Louis to bring you more insights from
the grand chour please follow us on
social media of St Louis chess club and
Grand chest
[Music]
tour hello and welcome back and it's the
penultimate round of the sink field cup
and there been three draws already but
one game is remaining between Richard
report and leevon aronian and let's
check out the results so far let's have
a look indeed three professional
grandmas drawers I wanted to say they
were professional giri taking a quick
draw against Fabiana caruana Grand
chestor Champion for Dominguez it was
also short but sweet again fash lra and
weslio and Yana pomi played All the
Right Moves to get to an opposite color
Bishop Eng
game we have a tie at the top because of
those uh results uh lanir and Wesley at
plus two and everything to play for it
just feels uh Peter like this the
singfield cup can go in a lot of
different ways yeah tomorrow tomorrow is
going to be interesting day with Wesley
having a rest day his fate is sort of
decided and it's he retires at plus one
decided is maybe not the right word but
it's completely out of his hands with
him having a buy due to younger's
withdrawal but there's going to be a lot
of exciting games tomorrow today has
been a bit of a dam squid frankly mhm uh
with one game still going on but not
very much uh necessarily happening on
that board as well is Leon defending uh
I think soundly if if a little stol yeah
passively yeah uh Richard Rapport you
see there at the board he's achieved
sort of the maximum activity of all his
pieces so far but he still needs to find
the break somewhere I'm not sure if
there's one to be
found uh and it feels like leevon is
correct in his assumption that you can
actually defend by depriving yourself
from all moves and then still holding
the resulting position exactly um it's
not the most attractive way of Defending
but in in this positions with Rooks and
Bishops of opposite color exactly it
often does hold right but Richard is
burning time on the clock trying to
generate a winning well not a winning
plan but a a plan that gets him in that
direction at least well he feels like
okay I mean all of his pieces are more
active his King is more active his
bishop and so forth and so on he's
reaching for B3 B2 B3 so you know you
you're tempted to continue the game but
in truth just as Peter is saying there's
just really not much to be done I mean
uh it's Fortress it's uh Bishops of off
of college you were about to say but
he's going to try yeah he is going to
try and the big question here is how is
leavon going to wait okay so step one I
mean do you wait with the king king C7
which I probably wouldn't because it's
on the same line as The Rook you're kind
of allowing uh the break B4 I would
probably be tempted just to step back
frankly to play Bishop to C7 okay I do
allow B4 in this case but I also gives
me a rook check which means that your
king is not going to take my Pawn on E5
and lose the pawn on D3 your king is
probably just going to step back to E4
so I this at least gives us something to
calculate so uh let's take a look at
this bishop C7 before I'm very much
enjoying the way the engine holds this
position because we've been talking
about this being like you just defend
defend defend defend we never have any
moves Machin says
Nope time to launch massive amounts of
counterplay by generating this passer on
the outside that's a shot and playing
actively from now on and this apparently
is a comfortable draw the question is
what happens if we take twice right okay
the evaluation has actually dropped from
a very comfortable equality to what I
assume is still a draw but it it feels
like this is an improvement I'm still
not quite sure where the wind will come
from after something like I don't
know7 and then back
okay and this is actually very
instructive because after the Rooks come
off it would seem that this is a four
against four opposite color Bishop
ending right but this one so weak and so
far away from the black king that a very
very straightforward plan of just coming
over to F7 and picking it up because the
only Square you can protect it is f8 so
let's just give black a chance to get it
to f8 but then you still get chased away
from the pawn the king will go to G7 not
G6 G7 denying the f f square and then
this Falls and once this Falls the game
is over so this is one thing to avoid
but after Rook C4 if you actually once
again if you preserve some sanity and
don't allow Rook
C6 it's scarier than it was but
apparently you're still not really
finding any way in for white and then
there is also this extremely funny idea
of suddenly remembering that you you can
also be active and you can also generate
threats and know maybe not for a win but
you definitely do want to to do this and
if you don't have B3 before as an option
or at least let's put it like this if if
B3 before doesn't actually give you
anything you're extremely Limited in
what you can do against Bishop C7 my
next move is Bishop D6 as Yanka said
we're not putting the king behind
behind the xray on the C file so we
always have those replies to B3 I do
think we have Bishop C7 on the board B
C7 played and this is where it could
potentially get a bit interesting
because uh Richie is arriving I think at
the point where if he wants to do
something he probably should do it now
because doing it on like a minute and a
half on the clock if by some miracle the
game actually becomes sharper you would
like to have some time to work out
what's going on now just exactly what
you were saying uh Richie goes into a
5minute tank here or a six-minute tank
or even a 10-minute tank and plays the
move B4 and you get shocked by and then
you get surprised by let's say then it's
sort of like uhoh I really miss my clock
suddenly I think it's a very very
missable idea just just
because not that it's very unusual it's
also a bit unusual but mainly because I
think by this point you've conditioned
yourself to think leevon is only just
looking how to trade more pieces and
defend so you don't even entertain a
thought of black doing something that
changes the the course of the game so
you just don't look at any sacrifices or
uh active moves at all when I was a kid
Joy I absolutely loved those uh tactics
where there were Pawn breakthroughs
right yeah you you sacrifice one
invisible squares yeah and this is
almost a pawn breakthrough but in
reverse because the move B4 white is
thinking okay I'm G to open it up for
myself then the move B5 creating a past
apod is a real stunner but I I do
remember wasn't it the Kasparov kpov
matches like there was one with a night
end game and someone went H4 H5 and it
was met with astonishment and crowd went
wild G4 that was uh a a great victory by
anat kpof in one of the world
championship matches and Gary was really
bummed out by that game in particular
and uh remember andr soran adoran who
was second for Kasparov says but hey man
you were the one trading all the pawns
we did you just snapped them off the
board you didn't give us a chance to
even look at uh the move G4 which karp
off won uh the move B5 by the way that
would be really a stunner I mean that
would uh because the I mean very very
very much so the players been kind of
one goal if you will I mean uh White has
some small nibble he's trying to push
and Bully his way around and the move B5
says you've Overlook something sir uh
yeah I I think it's almost impossible to
see because of that and what happens if
white Waits says you know what let's
not I have an idea Rick Rick to E4 you
were there yeah so so my idea was if you
went Rook D6 I was going to step back to
King C4 and claim that B4 is going to
come with more control and here I was
just thinking
move I need I need that I'm going back
to my original plan which was R Rook E3
is there anything I can see Bishop F5
okay yeah but now we can even maybe not
let you do them but I I assume you can
sort of triangulate with the Rook
eventually and yeah and get us to play
King B7 here and play Bishop F5 but yeah
the the bishop on e4 shockingly doesn't
actually improve your situation such a
great deal because the brakes are still
not really deciding anything and now we
can keep the the King on these squares
which denies your king more squares and
response I think my complain to this one
though uh Joy might be your you just I'm
not 100% sure you on the board just a
moot point
and did you just see Leon rolling up his
sleeves I suspect I know I mean this
might be asking too much of leavon but I
suspect that B5 flittered through his
Consciousness there and and and the good
thing for Leon on the on the flip side
of what we're discussing in this
particular position it looks absolutely
spectacular because of how many pawns
are hanging yes but he can start by
taking on B4 with the c pawn and then
play B5 which leads to pretty much the
same positions exactly that's what I
wanted to say C5 takes B4 C3 takes B4
and now this tactic this break through
tactic of B6
B5 throws the
game wide open and by the way very
unusual situation on the clock there
just wanted to attract attention to it
once one player a full hour ahead on the
clock there yeah oh my goodness uh let's
just look at how a bad tournament for
Richard could get much worse A4 takes B5
thank you I've won a pawn now the
position after A4 four and who is
playing for a win because if our Rook
tries to step back well Black's King is
going to step up um is this bad no it's
not bad for white at all it's still it's
still very much within the margins
you're not going to lose this I'm not
good no B5 a B5 A4 you can play
something like Rook C3 King B6 doesn't
really generate four yeah Rook of four
we go we still have our own play a pawn
doesn't really Queen so we can actually
continue uh doing doing our own thing
here yeah it's it's fine okay I I
pa but but then we also we also have con
to play against this guy I don't need B5
so much as Rook B3 Peter but I think I'm
first of all I think I can take I don't
know why I'm supposed to be wors
here the king is coming to7 yeah this
one this one will get picked up in
exactly the same way as it always has
been uh uh ooh Le by the way has already
taken on B before once with the correct
Pawn in order to play B5 if he wants to
play if he wants to play and there he is
he's played the move C5 takes B4 Prelude
or not to B6 B5
Joy is leavon going is he going to get
rambunctious and try B6 B5 or is he just
going to keep it yeah he he likes
activity when it's presented to him it's
definitely going through his
yeah I think so by now by now it is yeah
but you were just pointing out a
situation where White's Bishop actually
got back to A2 in time I think we're
it's it's not like white runs any kind
of significant risks here you can also
play the engine says you can even play
Rook C5 in case of A3 it just gets gets
chased down with Rook C3 because it can
no longer be supported we just going to
pick it up and if you play Rook D6 Rook
D4 I drop back to C3 I play Rook C4 once
again we've controlled everything we're
also not better after King D6 is the
issue uh King B6 apologies black is
completely fine here because all of
these this this whole structure is very
vulnerable right but white isn't like
the Aon is reasonably comfortably
controlled B5 that was
the how much time did he take on that B5
not that long for such a committal
decision wow yeah pretty certain that
he's thinking about on Richard's time by
the way that is for me um an
indication of what a great player leavon
aronian is for seriously uh for the
better part of the entire game he's
played it in this passive I'm keeping
I'm keeping but Underneath It All he
also says let me explore my chances when
I get the chance and this is why I was
so uh I might even use the word upset
even though like this is a kind of a
parasocial relationship that is not very
healthy for you but I felt that he's
really not doing himself Justice by
defending in the way that he was
defending him because he is one of the
more imaginative one of the more
exciting players around and for him to
choose this absolute paity over there
were some options earlier around move
3035 where he could have just forced
issues and just made I think a very
comfortable draw where he wouldn't need
to beg so to speak because he is to some
slight degree begging to to to to be you
know
let let off with a half a point right uh
but yeah now now he's back to doing what
he is doing master master after your
Rook C3 which keeps an eye on the a pawn
um a rook check right yeah Rook check
but then the king steps back and you can
yeah we go to we go to C5 you don't even
go to E4 we we go to C5 and the idea is
like it looks like I've achieved
self-made but I haven't actually
no I'm going to and there's a very funny
line where the king gets chased away all
the way to A5 but now I have my own
Bishop C8 Bishop A6 ideas so the game
actually equalizes out somehow and if
you go the other way to E4 with their
simple idea running to the H6 yeah this
is still fine but black can play like
King B6 for now I was thinking I mean
we've discussed this opposite C of
Bishop endgame for a while and doesn't
white have the advantage by going Rook
C6 not with the I think the difference
here is
uh you you you'll have to care about the
a will so what happens here is you have
to invest in Bishop B6 and then what I
can do about the pawn on H6 is I can put
I can put my Bishop on E3 yeah and then
I will always have G5 G4 as a response
to King G6 so this is completely safe
even at the cost of an E5 P I don't
think we care about E5 Pawn very much
exactly exactly A5 A4 on the board and
the the game flares a
new when you when Richie saw the move
B5 do you think that caused a little bit
of a flutter I think there was there was
a flutter yeah because uh you you feel
like now you can at least misplay it
because until that moment there was
really nothing you could do apart from
blundering some random mate in one
Summer by it's happened it's happened
loing youing completely in somewhere uh
he really had no absolutely no Pathway
to losing the game now he knows there
will be situations where he might be in
danger but I'm pretty sure he knows uh
any kind of semi- precise continuation
from here will be fine I don't I'm
certain we don't have it in our
statistics uh that's something that
we're going to have to make amends on
but what would be the biggest time Edge
difference of any sink fi cup that was
very difficult
to that's what I'm saying that's why I
brought it up as a topic of discussion
could an hour's difference on the clock
be meaningful the
position okay is balance a draw hoing to
the engine but it's suddenly got a
little bit dicey right yeah this is no
this is no misplay sorry rasa I'm just
ging I'm just giggling because uh you
reminded me of the scene that I saw and
the faress chess open which is a lovely
tournament in Norway and there the the
the players were not giving extra time
per move and I I just happened to pass
one board and one poor person was there
I think on 15 seconds and the opponent
had like an hour and so the poor person
was
like like this and the the the one with
54 minutes was leaning
back maybe making a
move yeah at the ready one of the
funniest things I've seen well it's only
funny it's only funny for one
side I've been in those situations and
you can be exceptionally cruel yes you
can really be exceptionally cruel in the
in the shoes of the person who has the
more time because I think if you want to
maximize your chances of winning that
game you actually do at some point need
to like tank for 25
minutes and your opponent by that point
will just go completely stir crazy you
just just make a move give me something
to respond to you know and yeah it's
it's just not a good feeling yeah you
yeah uh Brotherly Love on on on that
story of uh Brotherly Love uh
Grandmaster Robert burn was playing his
uh opponent Donald Burn and Donald was
in that situation where he had like a
minute to Robert's
hour and Donald whispered across the
board Robert I really have to go to the
bathroom would you mind not moving for
the next 10 minutes and what did Brother
Robert say to brother Donald no go to
the toilet on your own
time what are brothers for Rook C6
question you and actually and actually
this is just an immediate draw for
because if you don't take on C6 you
actually worse here with black you
you're very much incentivized not to
fool around you have to take and play
King B6 which makes a very comfortable
draw there's not a single issue with the
draw there because white still needs to
control the a pawn which means that you
you have to give up on C6 you have to
play like King C4 giving up on C6 let me
let me just go with it a yeah but A3 you
still have to give up on C6 you King I I
wanted to make a b line over here yeah
but uh do you still go for the same you
still go for the same plan right tell me
what it is putting the bishop on F do
you take this one first yeah let's let's
take it let's take it and now Bishop B6
okay and now I'm in yeah you're in Well
Done congratulations Round of Applause
Bishop to E3 and you're going to meet
king T H6 with G4 check and the bishop
can't dance at two weddings oh you know
that you know that tune huh the two
bridesmaides that story about the
Brotherly Love reminded me of the
perhaps the most famous Slow Roll I
think in televis poker history Slow Roll
yeah yeah cuz there was the I will I
will probably Butch it by mixing up some
of the names but I think there was a
story
where uh a player went all in and I
think the player tanking with Aces was
sha
DB and there was another player at the
table who basically really needed to go
to go and there was some time until the
break and Sean tell him run I'll think
for like five minutes and he thought for
five minutes with ases to to to give the
person time to come back
from uh no I think he won that I was I
think is a very it's a very famous story
if I mix up the names I'm I I will feel
very ashamed but I don't think I have I
think it was also specifically against
the one person you can slow roll in the
entire poker world I think it was
against men the master but I might be
wrong about that
one yeah a beautiful
story to my eyes I don't know who the
people were I don't know the head I
don't know how much was wagered some
someone went the
toilet I think that was the the punch
line
yeah where they say
they make
it uh Rook C6 uh the funny part is about
this move Rook C6 is there's nothing to
think about right here well you can play
bishop d8 and try to lose can yeah okay
and try to lose but you're advised not
to so I mean when leavon went for B5 he
had to consider that Rook C6 was
actually a uh legit answer to his whole
Pawn sacrifice
idea yeah so do you think he's just
recalculating he takes yeah he's just
recalculating uh just to make sure now
we are in pure opposite color of Bishop
engame King D6 on the board leavon just
has to see this nice maneuver of
transferring the bishop to the C1 H6
diagonal I don't think this will even be
asked because you that way you might
actually run into some potential issues
with white I think that that whole line
we we had it on the screen somewhere I
I'll find it yeah it's somewhere here uh
if you if you enter this and you also go
in with King G6 like here like you can
still take on E5 at pretty much any
point then this will be a draw but if
you do this you you you have to go back
yeah no I was expecting this this will
lose because the as they callous legs
exactly yeah as as they're called the
trous legs will will tear the the bishop
apart and you can't keep control of both
of both so you haven't lost yet but you
absolutely have to start making a be
back to safety uh so I'm pretty sure
that uh Richie will just be completely
uninterested in asking whether liveon
finds Bishop B6 Bishop B3 trouser legs
trouser legs
bridesmaids where does trouser legs come
from from the from and we have two
bridesmaids we the the the ponds are
about to become a bride so two Brides
made I've only I've only gotten married
twice
trouser legs trouser legs okay well uh a
new chest term being minted uh right
here do know you guys knew it I didn't
know it I mean I'm saying it's newly
minted for me I mean uh King B6 on the
board uh everybody uh we were saying
somebody was saying L um lanir once
spent an hour on a single move so that
might have been a tight uh a Time
disparity of an hour what's your
record
um I joined a lot of people and it was
the first time I ever played Vish andand
it was the match in Du by USA versus
India we were playing on board one he
was white and he probably played the
whole game and I'm not joking 40
minutes 40 minutes for the whole game it
was a 70 move game that ended in a draw
and I got into time pressure twice in
this game and I complained to my
teammates I said my God this Indian kid
he played the whole game in 40 minutes
they said yes sir he was gone 20 minutes
from the
board I mean vishy was well known for
for for for for making the whole game in
15 minutes no I meant I meant so I had a
literally a 90 minute disparity
disparity between him and I it's a good
story and it's an answer I wasn't
expecting because normally you don't
keep track of these things but I was
more in terms of what's your record for
time spent on one move oh no I I I never
went into those big big hour tanks but I
definitely numerous times 30 minute
tanks yeah I I sometimes after even 30
minutes I just got tired calculating I
just got to make a by the way we didn't
see any of these efforts
I think what will happen now just I
think my board will be used for the last
time in this broadcast now and then
we'll switch to yers just to show one
line here after King takes C6 ju just so
that you don't have to discuss anything
anymore you go B5 check you go King B4
go A4 A3 just to make sure he play goes
A4 A3 and then no King will ever
penetrate anywhere because once again if
you in this position somehow teleported
to F7 white wins but it's kind of far
away so yeah this is very very peaceful
I assume something like this will happen
uh quite quickly uh and yeah feels like
this one is is winding down so we can
return to telling stories to to our
audience how about yourselves uh longest
thing your longest you're bringing back
bad memories for bad men yeah I want to
say that one of the kind of remnants of
I I CAU the very very last two sessions
of the Kasparov school but lck wasn't
there anymore uh he was still alive but
he wasn't really active Gary would
occasionally come give a simal or just
like look at your games for a couple
days and then go away uh but you were
given a lot of instructions and in those
years they were very formalized
instructions people were very serious
about giving you practical advice you
were supposed to follow and the two
things that stuck with me from from
those uh sessions
where and this was very much uh a
remnant of but Wick's Legacy butwick was
very serious about making the first 15
moves in 30 minutes time to give you to
give yourself time to think about the
fall up to think about the middle game
so very structured from that moment on
until I am now fairly grown up person I
still I sit down and I Mark I mark my
score sheet and one of the things I put
on the score sheet is 15 and then a
hyphen and then I will note down how
much time I spend on 15 moves even
though I've broken that rule many a time
I no longer care but it's just something
that you do I was taught to do that and
I do that even now and another thing was
they said in order to kind of be more
conscious of how how you spend your time
not down the time you spend on a move
which I always did and because of that I
actually I think know fairly well
exactly what my record is and it's from
a junior ter I think it was from my
first ever Soviet Championship under 18
okay so we're talking I was like 12 and
a half wow and in one of the earlier
rounds I played a very theoretical
Spanish in which my opponent surprised
me by a novelty which was a story of the
olden times you took all your theory
from the Yugoslav informant magazines
which were not very easy to come by in
in Soviet Russia so I didn't have the
latest issue but my opponent did and he
played something that was recommended in
the issue I didn't have and I sat down
and thought for like 65 minutes because
th those were leisurely time controls
you had plenty of time I think they were
maybe even two and a half hours for 40
yeah exactly and actually semi- refuted
an in an informant novelty at the board
and won that game and I was very very
proud of myself and I feel like I've
never broken that record I came like I
think I like 45 minutes were achieved
later in life but that was above an hour
65 impressive impressive stuff by the
way uh I want your to you to jump in on
this one too joy we do have a few moves
not any hourong things by the way but we
did see the move Bishop G4 to E D6 just
making sure that thou shall not pass any
further and we do have Bishop D6 on the
board y um and D6 doing a nice job of
potentially protecting the Aon my
longest thing well you see I'll be
honest with everyone I don't have the
biggest concentration ban so whenever I
go into a long think it's because I'm
somewhere in like analysis paralysis and
I can remember think Anis paralysis
remember thinking for a long time when I
played humpy canaru at the World Cup
knockout match and it was just
indecision I didn't quite know whether I
should s into an end game where we were
equal porns but she had a a completely
pass porn on the queen side and I should
have just done it I should have had the
confidence but it was just this type of
thing you know just paral yeah I mean
yeah it was there was no calculation
involved it was just simply indecision
so that's why I say brings up bad
memories I work much better on a shorter
time frame ah nice uh by the way that's
incredibly impressive to sit at the
board and concretely refute your
opponent's preparation well refute is
may be strong but I found something that
was actually missed in the informant
that was not my idea was not mentioned
as a reply and I was was immensely proud
of myself and I realized that later
great story um it sounds like you had
some courses with the Bob Bing where it
was very structured that you were
supposed to do things by 15 minutes but
like you say you kind of violated the vi
within 30 mve I don't I don't think it's
possible realistically to stick to stick
to the Whole 30 15 and 30 idea right you
sometimes just get surprised in the
opening and we abely have to invest time
by the way I think we are rap rapidly
heading towards that draw because Richie
has taken a step back with King C3 once
again you can play A3 King 3 A2 and just
get get more stuff off the board I would
jump on that5 Bishop C4 check you're not
actually or even Bishop D7 B7 Che Bish
G7 check oops I would have lost my Pawn
there probably not the game though prob
notame possibly not the game but best
not A3 uh A3 looks like a a very very
good move indeed just to trade off the a
pawn for the B Pawn but do you trade it
off though you go A3 and I stop it
immediately and go Bishop A2 Bishop A2
but then King B5 I force it to play
Bishop C4 check I go back
yeah you can even go forward back yeah
thank you you can even go to even
forward this far yeah sure zigzag King
and Bishop I'm pretty sure the that will
be a four straw after Bishop B3 check
just going back and forth a bit curious
about exactly what lean is thinking
about here because the position doesn't
seem to inspire a lot of children
choices King B6 maybe but I'm not sure
what that does that the move A4 A3
doesn't right no uh A3 just looks
so predictable so so obviously
strong a besides your Bishop A2 I
actually was thinking that you were
going to go King B3 with the idea that
King B5 gets met by Bishop C4 chck uh
but I thought A2 the way to just for
that was the intention Bishop takes B
before exactly and then bring the king
over to F6 and there really isn't very
much to play for
exactly okay and hour for for for Richie
okay I mean obviously he's had this
slightly upper hand since time control
of move 40 uh is is this another one of
those schools of Hard Knocks do you feel
badly that you didn't get a win even
though know you worked hard or do you
just say hey look I knew it was going to
be a draw I had I think today he okay um
because I I would be very shocked if at
any point he actually felt like this is
now this is now getting serious yeah he
of course did the right thing in in
trying as much as he could because
leevon gave him the you know the freedom
of the city right yeah and uh of course
you try but U it didn't really feel like
it was very serious
I think somebody who like Yan for
instance yesterday mhm where he clearly
out prepared ala and ala at some point
started thinking about every move for a
very very long time and perhaps making
the slightly sub second best choices not
bad choices but not the best choices
right I think Yan would feel a lot more
grieved by yesterday than whatever
Richie will feel after today exactly I
think I mean Richie looks very sad but
that's because just the whole tournament
is uh it feels like a write off it's
just not a good tournament but today
hasn't really been bad
exactly yeah yeah for Richard he will no
longer be able to finish on an equal
score he's on minus two right and that's
always a disappointing thought that you
never you haven't manage to get 50% for
sure yeah and returning to your uh story
about vishy uh playing very very fast
yeah playing very very fast one of my I
think proud life achievements was we
played in a round robin in Sophie in
2006 and uh I think I probably lost with
black because I always lost to him with
black it discontinued throughout my
career no no that's actually that's
wrong because that was the one
tournament where I did okay I think we
drew my white game it was a double round
drin and in the black game he misplayed
something out of the opening in a very
sharp anti Marshal and I suddenly had a
massive
attack and he started thinking and at
some point he got got down to below 5
minutes and he started making those
hyphens
and yeah instead of instead of a move in
in those times without increment you you
you're allowed when you fall below a
certain threshold to to to to not write
down the just to mark down that the move
was made and then restore the the score
sh once the time control has passed I
still didn't win I never won a single
game against him in classical uh
obviously uh but after the game finished
he told me this was the first time in
his entire life he had to do that that
he got into time trouble he actually
stopped writing down moves not not time
Trav the time travel that he felt upset
about enough to stop noting down moves
and I thought success result you know
like this is the full extent of yeah the
full extent by the way guys A3 on the
board on the board expecting King B3 and
no
Bishop C4 well it prevents King B5 and
now we will Shuffle yeah bishop or King
B6
waiting what are you going to
do if you go King B3
A2 if you move your Bishop King
B5 so King B6 and we're just saying okay
I'm waiting for you to make a a
declarative statement
uh if you march towards the pawn I'll
play
A2 guys I I mean I know it I know we're
just briming with energy and excitement
but I do feel a three move repetition
coming on yeah Bishop somewhere yeah
actually putting it yeah this is this
actually making it quicker he made it
very
clear if you play King
C6 what what what king
C6 what's Wednesday's
dinner Bishop C4 Bishop C
[Music]
and the
magic magic I do like that display
Bishop e played with a
flare and there you go the players are
calling over the Arbiter both players
know it is a draw between Richard report
and leavon aronian felt as though leavon
couldn't wait to make that
claim he was Johnny on the spot and for
Chris bird this this is a marvelous
opportunity to polish the table for
tomorrow's
game Peter it's been one of those rounds
what can I tell you I mean you're going
to have to sum it all up for us with
some final thoughts as we get ready for
our ultimate round for tomorrow let's
hope tomorrow is different let's hope so
uh it should be because tomorrow the the
outcome of the whole tournament will be
decided and uh also some of the
conversations that we've been having
over the past few days about the
qualification implications have been
sort of resolved by today yes so I think
people can breathe somewhat easier and
just play with more freedom but yeah
today has been a quiet day and uh very
much hoping tomorrow will bring more
more fireworks looking forward to
absolutely as we see Fabby and elenir
both tied for first everything to play
for Juan Wesley so he goes in with a buy
he's at plus one he's in the club house
over and he
waits for results yes and it was a
peaceful day it was the Calm before the
storm because tomorrow everything will
be decided a champion will be crowned
very good so it's going to be exciting
but we're going to wait for the
results here it comes and there here
they come it's uh four draws I believe
four drawers and here are the standings
of the today's round Fabiana Carana 4
and 1/2 points out of seven lenia
Dominguez 4 and 1/2 points out of seven
but for Wesley so who also has 4 and 1/2
points but his is out of a eight
remember the game discrepancy is because
Yan Kristoff dudo has withdrawn and
everything to play for tomorrow yes
anything can happen we can potentially
see a Soul Leader a soul Champion we
could even see a five way tie
tomorrow everything is going to be
decided because these are the pairings
Nashi has white against Anish giri he
was on minus one Maxim Vash NRA faces
off against Ali Resa fuja a victory for
him could also see him tie for first
place leavon aronian still on he's on
even scor as well again a victory over
Dominguez would ensure that there is a
potentially a tie for first place and
Fabiano Carana plays Richard raor Wesley
has the
buy and we're going to do it all
tomorrow as we go to our ultimate game
our final round we will be crowning uh
the sville cup uh Champion once again a
big congratulations to Fabiano our grand
chest tour Champion 2023 it's been a
fabulous year for Fabiano uh a very
deserved winner thank you for joining us
we'll see you all tomorrow see you
then
[Music]
this has been a presentation of the St
Louis chess club any reproduction or
distribution of this content without the
express written consent of the St Louis
chess club is
prohibited